see
yeah I don't know if it's turned on or
not well the red light it seems to be
working we're getting that
test test
okay yes and finally I am uh Mike
moffatt uh very happy to be chairing
this uh this committee I was vice chair
last time around
um and uh
again this is a very important committee
not a heavy load but we've got some very
significant measures in front of us my
background real quick uh representative
sharloff mentioned running in 2004 I
don't know if you remember I ran I lived
in Concord at that time you probably
don't remember but I ran oh yeah that
Mike Moffett yeah I lived in Concord
then I I was uh I was unsuccessful in
2004 eventually moved to Loudoun where I
uh ran in 2014 that's where I met uh
representative Kerry uh my rate my first
race there rated in a tie which I I lost
unlike uh Landslide Larry who I
apparently won
what won his first raised by nine votes
and yes he was in the papers all through
November uh yeah so real quick I have
lived in Manchester I taught at Trinity
High School I've also served on the
education committee uh a couple terms
including last term when I did two
committees so I lived in Manchester
taught uh on many levels um was in the
Marine Corps active duty in the 80s uh
get out went back in in 1990 I was
working in Plymouth State and uh an
opening in Maine came up for uh dragons
and I met Commander Stapleton in uh in
Maine and so I asked my boss at Plymouth
a sports information director he said
could I look into this Reserve
opportunity and he's he said well you
get football games on weekends but we
could probably support that he said no
you're not going to let go to any wars
right and I said this is 1990 and I said
well the Berlin Wall is coming down and
looks like it's going to be pretty
peaceful so before the year was over it
was dug in on the Saudi Arabia in
Kuwaiti border scuds and and we went
through the burning oil well field so
yeah you never know uh represent
Emmanuel mentioned he joined and for
those who just came in
um he joined in 2001 to kill Bin Laden
he's on the record is saying that's why
he joined and
and
um so well speaking of 9 11 I was
activated after 9 11 I served with
General Franks at uh at sevcom
um did not at that time go into theater
although in 2010 uh I I think it was the
oldest Marine in Afghanistan that was 54
almost 55 on the special assignment they
are glad to get over there uh and then
Bin Laden was killed the next year as
you probably recollect representative
Manion so anyway very happy to be here
very honored to have a chance to uh uh
be part of leadership and to be on this
on this great committee
uh so that's my story so we have some
wonderful guests some of you I know have
been on the committee before and you've
heard some of this before I say the
general this year I heard you had a
dentist appointment but you're but
you're
you're good to go
well that's that's great
well we'll get right to it um and uh
represent Rollins uh our vice chair also
had a medical thing restaurants can you
would you mind taking just a minute or
two and just uh let everybody know uh
who yeah where he came from
and we're I know if we're live or not
but
representative skip Rollins representing
Newport unity and Charlestown growing up
in Newport my whole life and this is my
a term on the Veterans Affair committee
thank you Mr Vice chair
uh sixth term
okay
so we have a a schedule
where we're going to uh have some
special guests give us some orientations
as to their
their jobs and back on and and
this is Deputy adjective General Warren
Perry who's going to lead off and he's
going to talk to us about uh
community-based military programs and
more so I'm gonna run through another
meeting okay
I'm going to the meeting tag didn't want
to come to okay
so so Deputy ashington General Warren
Perry who is the gentleman moving around
uh handing out the material he has
another meeting to go to but uh Tha the
the adjective General General mcglitis
is here didn't expect him to be here so
this is great to see you General
and uh
uh Warren is already gone apparently
but as a flag officer I know you were
fearless and and uh
ready to ready to roll so General
welcome
you know hey thanks sir uh certain
community members for the record I'm
David michelitis the agent general for
the New Hampshire
in the commissioner of the Department of
military Affairs and Veterans Services
um the handout in front of you so what I
plan on doing today is um to hand out in
front of you to the right hand side is
the National Guard to the left-hand side
is mostly our portfolio of the military
Affairs and Veterans Services piece
I will briefly give you the broad
overview in the New Hampshire National
Guard and then I'll hand it over to our
specific experts on the veteran surfaces
portfolio
so big picture New Hampshire National
Guard both Army and air is about 3 000
strong of military service Members
Federal civilians and state employees
the Air National Guard is about 1100
Airmen at peace Air National Guard base
on the Seacoast we are very fortunate to
have be the only Air National Guard Wing
in the country with that new kc-46
refueler of which we have 12. on this
three billion dollars of assets sitting
on that Runway that tarmac out there and
just to let you know and so you know a
couple really exciting things have been
going on is number one we're getting the
active duty back there's an active duty
Squadron associated with our Air
National Guard so we're going to have
about 150 active duty Airmen start
pcsing permanent change of station
coming back and relocating to New
Hampshire or the Seacoast to help us man
those 12 new airplanes because we had
the old airplane we had eight the new
airplane is 12. we need active duty
Manning to help us with the maintenance
in the pilots to keep fielding and
flying those planes
a really unique achievement is about two
months ago we set a record an airboat
Melody air Mobility command of all
transports refuelers cargo plans uh flew
with 36-hour non-stop Mission we left
peace they flew across North America
they went out to Hawaii refueled F-22
Raptors flew around Guam and came back
and we put three crews on that plane and
the reason was is to show um reassurance
to our asia-pacific partner specifically
Taiwan that we can Flex our Global power
anywhere in the world it was a truly
amazing flight first in its kind the
wing flew first 23 hours on an earlier
Mission a month later through 36 hours
so we are strategically relevant with
that new refueler and we have Global
reach
go to the Army National Guard the Army
National Guard is about 1800 strong you
probably see them in the communities
there we have about 17 armories
throughout the state if you look at this
little pamphlet it just shows you where
we are located geographically
so we're located throughout the state
um
you know you probably heard or saw us
with covid and that's us right we are
the only Department of Defense
organization with a dual federal state
mission right it's the National Guard we
call Title 32 our commander-in-chief is
a governor he has the ability to
activate us and you probably will
typically see or hear about us for two
things one the first was covid for about
two years we supported the state of New
Hampshire with just under 800 soldiers
and Airmen activated
and the second thing you probably hear a
lot about us is search and rescue so New
Hampshire Fish and Game does not have
helicopters we do last year we did 15
search and rescues in the white modern
national forest and throughout the state
um set a record a 88 increase what we
did the previous year
and so that's when you typically here
see us
um when you put all together you look at
the sort of quality life of our service
members and you'll see a sheet on the
right hand side that says the New
Hampshire National Guard was nominated
to be the number eight business in
business New Hampshire magazine
and the criteria was twofold run one
number one was um we had to have over 50
of our full-time employees you know fill
out a survey and number two is based
upon the benefits that department
defense provides for our service members
and you rack and Sack those two major
criteria those two factors and we were
selected to be the eighth best business
to work for in the uh New Hampshire
what is the biggest challenge for the
New Hampshire National Guard uh it's
this simple filling our formations
um there's no line at our door that next
Generation they're propensity to serve
in childhood obesity is crushing us the
International Guard does a relatively
good job because it's proximity to the
University of New Hampshire where about
20 percent of our Junior soldiers and
Airmen are enrolled in the community
college system either in the community
college system of New Hampshire or the
University of New Hampshire because the
legislature thank you provides our
service members with their free tuition
waiver at any University
that is a big big deal when you ask
these younger kids
um why do you join it's usually three
reasons right
for plenty to serve challenge of the
military culture and the educational
benefits that is a big big deal for us
when about 20 of our forces in college
um so the International Guard because
it's proximity UNH and just the mission
that it has we do relatively well
um the Army National Guard we are
struggling significantly and I think
most people probably hopefully are aware
that last year was the worst recruiting
year for the Army as an Enterprise for
active duty National Garden reserves
since the end of the volunteering draft
in 1972.
um it was horrendous and it did not go
well if you look at the active duty Army
I just give the simple statistic
the active duty Army missed their
numbers by over 15
000.
um in simple parlance that's an army
division there's only 10 of them
that's how bad recruiting was and it
trickled down to the state of New
Hampshire it's just what we call a war
for talent low unemployment rate and
there's just no line on our door so
anything you can influence or help us
fill our formations it would be
sincerely appreciated
um on the Mel on the veterans department
military Affairs and Veterans Services
I'm going to start handing off to some
of our folks here
broadly speaking the big picture we have
25 state employees dedicated to veteran
programs right so 25 state employees
dedicated to three sort of like uh
organizations State veterans cemetery
the division of community-based military
programs and
um the division of Veterans Services
so when governor sununu in the
legislature in I think 2019 codified uh
the organization or reorganization of
the Department of military and Veterans
Services he put everything except Health
Care
underneath dmabs so I usually like to
tell people is that's what we are
everything about health care we're not
the Manchester VA and we're not the
veterans home but anything that touches
a 90 plus thousand veterans in the state
of New Hampshire typically goes through
us
so if it's a veteran service officer for
a service disability if it's a final uh
pressing Place dignified resting place
for our veterans or whether it's a
community outreach program through a
veteran Friendly's business initiative
anything that touches veterans it's on
us more than myself and I'll sit here
and then introduce you to the rest of
the staff
with it
General before you do that uh before we
lose you you take just a minute or two
and you and like we just did a whip
around and briefly said where we came
from and how we get to be where we are I
I think some folks especially some of
the newer folks uh maybe don't have a
clear understanding of the adjective
General position uh so if you could take
a minute or two and just tell us where
you came from and just uh describe the
the tag uh position if you would
okay thanks sir um so I grew I'm uh
lifelong New Hampshire kid I grew up in
Manchester with the Manchester Memorial
High School went to St George's Regal
Orthodox Church
um I was fortunate enough to get a uh
accepted the United States Military
Academy of West Point I attended West
Point I served Five Years on active duty
as an infantryman
um in a mechanized infantry unit and
then from there I transitioned either to
reserver National Guard units so I've
been serving for over 30 plus years in
either infantry Special Forces
um or units in the New Hampshire
National Guard
um I've always been a New Hampshire
resident except when I was not when I
was on active duty in
um I joined the New Hampshire National
Guard in
2007 but I've been serving since 1987
since I've been commissioned from West
Point the adjunct General roles on
responsibility
it's different in every single state and
territory
generally speaking you're the action in
general of your state Military
Department
in other states you can also be the
commissioner of Emergency Management or
the commissioner of veteran services so
we usually say that it's like the big
three in New Hampshire for for this
position is the big two is veteran
services in the military department but
if you went to Maine he's uh their
action General's in charge of Emergency
Management and if you went to Vermont
they're exactly like myself and if you
go to Massachusetts they're only the
military uh uh Commander
the rosary actor in general um it's
generally speaking on the army or
military side it's you know our army and
Air National Guard is a combat Reserve
Force for the United States Army United
States Air Force so my number one
priority is to man and train and equip
those forces
so 80 of my time uh in my center of
gravity is usually Washington DC where I
go to National Guard Bureau the Pentagon
to leverage uh resources for whether
it's Personnel equipment money to bring
back to either build new armories build
new maintenance facilities to manage and
equip our formations
by Statute the job or position is
someone like a judge where they try to
keep the uh the action General
apolitical so I could serve till age 65
and it doesn't transition and maybe like
other commissioner positions do might do
with changeover of political parties of
Governors
thank you very much General and before
you hand it off uh I I have one question
and and if anybody else has a question
for a tag the gadget in general I'm sure
you'll take a question or two but my
question and thank you if you're Candor
about the recruiting uh problem I knew
there was an issue I didn't realize it
was is as Grave as you described thanks
for your honesty on that that's
something that we do need to know
um my question is in terms of uh
recruiting I believe the ages have
changed we in recent times in terms of
uh the age range who can look at service
could you speak to that uh yes sir so
generally speaking you can now join up
to age 40. the Navy went to I think 41
but um it went from I think 38 to 40 so
if you're 40 years of age or less you
typically can now join so they just keep
expanding and expanding because our pool
of candidates Keys keeps shrinking and
shrinking
40. okay that's interesting
um we I we found out earlier General
that one of our members uh had a perfect
ASVAB score uh I don't think he's 40 yet
you may want to recruit him uh I but I
don't
I I will leave that to you all questions
for for the general
seeing none uh Joe thanks so much for
being here yes uh representative gagne
yes
thank you General
uh did I hear you say you your active
duty is that correct no I I started my
uh military career on active duty but
I'm a member of the New Hampshire
National Guard okay so it's it's not a
full-time job but it's full-time pretty
much it it is a full-time job so Monday
to Friday I'm a state employee
who wears a uniform and then I must be
the member of the National Guard on the
weekends my week and a month there were
annual training and stuff like that so
it is a full-time job okay thank you
other questions
if not uh General sure if you want to
hand this off and introduce uh some of
the folks who are going to give us
follow one briefs
so the next three briefers from the
Department of military Veteran Affairs
uh I'm not sure which order you all
going to comment uh Sean you first
so the first one will be the division of
community-based military programs um
regrettably our administrator Amy Cook
recently took another job with nami New
Hampshire the National Association of
mental health so the administrator uh
position is vacant and uh but and then
after that will be uh the Veteran
Cemetery and division of veteran
services and I'll stay here through
their brace answering additional
questions
foreign
Mr chairman and other
individuals on the community this
morning I was not prepared to speak
because Warren Perry told me I was just
going to sit in the back there behind
the tag and not have to say anything so
here I am I didn't have any prepared
remarks and I do apologize for that so
if you don't mind I'd just like to brief
you on what we have included in your
packets this morning
first of all my name is Sean Jones I'm
almost a 25-year
state employee and I am a resident of
the State of New Hampshire have been
well since I was born so I'm a native
and I grew up over in Hillsboro and I
joined the Coast Guard Reserve in 1987
while I was still in high school and I
retired out of the Coast Guard Reserve
in 2011 and during that time I also
served in various State positions and
I've been with the community-based
military program comes now since
February of last year so I'm new to my
position I'm a program specialist too
and I work on writer and homelessness
issues and suicide prevention
initiatives
so the mission statement of the division
of community-based military programs is
to collaborate coordinate communicate
with military and civilian providers
groups to promote the delivery of
quality services to New Hampshire
veterans service members and their
families
what we do there are five full-time
employees including myself providing
awareness resources and Technical
Services we integrate military and
civilian community and and collaborate
Coalition networks and strengthen
military civilian community supports by
integrating those supports into civilian
structures
we contribute to State oversight efforts
for New Hampshire care coordination
including services and supports
addressing substance misuse homelessness
Suicide Prevention mental health sexual
military trauma unemployment domestic
violence
education and legal support we
facilitate State planning processes to
improve access to net navigation
coordination of military civilian
Services is a port we advocate for
federal and state funding to Target
system changes to improve Services we
ensure cost efficiency through decreased
overlap service redundancy and increased
service Fidelity we authorize evaluate
and monitor the administration of
federal and state grants
some of our programs that we're
currently working on we launched a lunch
and learn services for the New Hampshire
veteran friendly business Network an
increased enrollment to 65 businesses we
secured funding to support efforts of
community organizations to increase
Mental Health Services and reduce social
isolation for New Hampshire veterans
we provided New Hampshire specific
information to 11
583 transitioning service members in New
Hampshire National and army guards New
Hampshire reservists and 23 military
installations around the country to
encourage transitioning military
families to choose New Hampshire as
their civilian home
it's
do you have any questions for you or for
the tag
so I think big pictures from the big
takeaways is it's this simple right it
was two people the legislature passed a
veteran Bill of Rights in 2020 and then
you resource three additional positions
so we thank you right so now we went
from two to five so it was
administrative admin assistant now we
have program Specialists to run
different programs whether it's homeless
lists uh homeless veteran homelessness
licensure and some other initiatives
when you look back at the year and you
look at this little slide or this card
you know one side is guard one side's uh
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services so the two or three big
rocks that just happened right one was
this initiative called ask the question
campaign
90 plus thousand veterans in the state
of New Hampshire only a third of them go
to the Manchester VA White River
Junction
so how do you get in touch with them at
a community mental health provider and
so what that initiative did was if
you're a veteran and you go to your
civilian doctor or that that then that
uh that facility the first thing should
happen is the nurse or uh PA might sit
down with you and say um are you a
veteran
and if you are it then generates a set
of questions so we can uh offer more
specific services for uh any issues with
veterans service of the veteran
population that was one number two is
you're honoring the veterans in general
so we initiated a with the employment
security a veteran friendly business
recognition program
so it's like uh bronze silver platinum
gold so there's different levels right
so an employer can say hey look I take
care of my veterans these are the things
I allow them to do and so we have a
structure a category that and I think
we're up to like 60-ish businesses so
that then turned into a lunch and learn
so those are a lot of just the different
initiatives that we're taking that
doesn't have to do with the veteran
service officers for pensions and
doesn't have to deal with the the
cemetery that's all our Outreach
programs that we provide
representative P Money
and thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
for taking my question Mr Jones
um approximately how many veterans are
homeless in the state of Minnesota New
Hampshire
uh currently uh at the last point of
time count that we had in January of
this year we had
um 95 veterans who were experienced
homelessness and it breaks down as 80
were in transitional housing
fiber and Emergency Shelters
six are in hotels and four are
unsheltered
we all have uh they all have been
assigned a provider to work with them on
getting them permanent housing some of
them have declined services but this is
an improvement from 2020 where there
were reported 116 veterans experience
homelessness in New Hampshire and 101
were in temporary transitional housing
and 15 were unsheltered so we are making
improvements and we are going to
continue to do so very good thank you
you're welcome
other questions for Sean
uh representative Kerry
do we have any sort of statistics on
veteran suicide
uh representative Kerry I do not have
that at this time
um I could get that information to you
though
I just want to point out that Sean is a
legionnaire former commander of post 88
in Loudon where he did a wonderful job
one quick comment or question uh we're
gonna hear from a lot of a number of
folks today we already have started we
have the generals card in our the
handout that was passed out what I would
like to put together have some help
putting together for everyone in our
committee and also for other people who
approach us is a a kind of a directory
if if we could get the best point of
contact I know I have Bill goudreau's
address I've
uh but we don't want to send everything
to the to the tags office so anyway at
some point in the next in the near
future if we could just uh get a good
directory with the best people to
contact so that we don't uh you know
bother the wrong people too much yeah
sir I think Bill might correct me but I
think every year or two were required by
a statue to send uh a veteran uh
resource directory guide out I'm just
not sure he'll he'll be able to tell us
uh with the status of it oh perfect that
yeah that's what we want to have the
latest and greatest for any more
questions for Sean Jones uh
representative Rollins
yes is this on
okay
um how many veteran homeless shelters do
we have in New Hampshire I know we have
the Liberty house I've been there before
are there other shelters throughout New
Hampshire that for for just for veterans
uh yes there is uh we do partner with
Harbor care they operate two in Nashua
and one in Manchester and there are
other non-profit agencies that we work
with throughout the state that do
provide some temporary housing for them
thank you you're welcome
okay other questions
Mr Jones Sean Mr Commander thank you for
uh a great unplanned for presentation
excellent thank you Mr chairman
sir and I'll be uh Sean Buck uh the
administrator and he's in charge of our
veterans cemetery
good morning everyone a pleasure to be
here
um saw you yesterday representative
Kerry
um so just a quick overview every I
think most everybody hopefully has been
to the veterans cemetery
um we have nine full-time employees uh
three part-time employees we do about a
thousand internments a year last year
was 1201 that's the most we've ever done
um a couple things I want to highlight
though um in case you don't understand
so the the veteran the cost for Burial
at the Veteran Cemetery is zero for a
veteran a qualified veteran pays nothing
if they're eligible through the VA then
the VA compensates Us by sending us a
plot allowance for each veteran and that
plot allowances change updated every
year on October 1st uh and then so we
apply for that so once the veteran is
interred we apply to the VA and they
reimburse us so roughly 50 percent or a
little bit more of the cost of the
Veteran Cemetery is reimbursed from the
federal government
um last year uh in June 1st we do to
your how much your help we passed the
burial equity for guards and reserves
Act
um frankly our state legislature our our
state legislators down in Washington did
a fantastic job they advocated for this
for years and so now starting June 1st
we bury members of the National Guard
and the reserve components in our state
veterans cemetery the requirement is is
that they complete their first term Of
Enlistment and they have an other than
dishonorable discharge they have to
demonstrate to us that they did complete
that enlistment and show me some sort of
discharge certificate that shows I did
my four years my five years my six years
we do not get reimbursed from the
federal government for that the state
covers their costs so we do we treat
them exactly so as far as they're
concerned it's no different we treat
them exactly the same no cost for the
veteran remember dependents it is a 350
fee due on the date of internment so up
to now we've buried 29 folks that have
fallen in under the barrel equity for
garden reserves super proud of our state
only three states that I know of bury
members of the garden reserves North
Dakota has been doing it from the
beginning since they opened their state
Veteran Cemetery they they that was part
of their agreement to open
Virginia I believe has done it but they
charge like fifteen hundred dollars to
the veteran if they're a member of the
garden Reserve to be interred and us and
we treat our members of the guard and
reserves exactly the same as we treat
those who are eligible under the active
duty
um super proud of that and when I talked
to North Dakota they bury like maybe six
or eight a year so we're up to 29 and
we're not even one year into it so this
program has really taken off I'm super
proud of that
second thing I want to highlight the
veterans cemetery Association we are
supported by a group of volunteers that
raises money on our behalf helps fund
projects on our behalf and the entire
Memorial walkway the veterans Heritage
Learning Center which is on the back of
the admin building all handled by the
veterans cemetery Association they do a
fantastic job they are a fantastic
organization
third events one of the things I've done
as Cemetery directors I've tried to make
our events very consistent so Memorial
Day this is prior to me May 30th 11
o'clock so May 30th not on the Monday
that everybody celebrates Memorial Day
the original Memorial Day May 30th 11
o'clock that's when we do our ceremony
uh reuse for bosquin we did do a little
change to that
um we no longer work with reads Across
America they are a fantastic
organization but we kind of broke away
from them we order our wreaths from a
New Hampshire company Three Rivers up in
Franklin and we do it always the first
Saturday of December at 10 30. so again
consistency reads Across America would
sometimes move around it'd be the second
week the third week no first Saturday
December if you come to the state
Veteran Cemetery that's when we're
putting out reefs and we order our
wreaths locally
um
and then the third event
well I guess that's the only two events
I really wanted to highlight
um
fourth volunteers we rely on our
volunteers one of our best programs is
the adopt a garden program we have
several volunteers they adopt they come
out they pick a garden usually it's near
a loved one or a place special for them
they help us tend that Garden they plant
they we provide them with the materials
but they do a lot of the labor I
generally only have five guys that have
to mow all the grass dig all the Grays
place all the heads to do everything
around the cemetery so the little fine
details of pruning flowers things like
that sometimes it's at the end of the
list so these volunteers are so
essential and they are fantastic we have
some that show up literally two three
times a week and they work in various
Gardens so it is awesome and we have
tons of other volunteer programs
volunteers clean our headstones
volunteer clean the memorial walkway it
is awesome it's a tremendous connection
to the community
lastly I want to let you know that we
have an expansion in case anybody
wonders we have 104 Acres we're good for
at least to the turn of the century I
believe
um in terms of space at the veterans
cemetery we do have an expansion
happening this coming fiscal year we're
going to add uh 10 years worth of
columbarium space so the niches where
people can put their cremated remains
we're building 12 structures uh well
over a thousand more niches to that
because we're running short we're about
we have about two and a half years of
Niche space left for uh columbarium so
we're going to expand that this coming
year
so now I stand open for your questions
about anything except David yeah I just
want to clarify one thing and just to
make sure you understand so uh Sean
served over 20 plus years in active duty
he's a veteran right I served eight plus
years active duty and the rest of the
guard of reserves I'm a veteran the
guard Barrel Equity act if you're a
national Guardsman or reservist who's
never activated you couldn't get buried
there
that's the difference that's why it's
Unique that's why we thank you because
we're only one of three states who honor
our part-time service members regardless
whether it's naval Reserve Marine
reserve we don't care but that person
still took an oath to the Constitution
to defend this nation against all
enemies formed a domestic it's just
equal treatment that's why it's Unique
and that's why we thank you
he said it better than I did thanks
uh questions for the next the other Sean
uh representative gagne
thank you Mr chairman
as a
Navy veteran
serving during the Vietnam war but was
never in country
and for my friend on the other side of
the colonel here
who was in Vietnam I thank you for the
welcome home for us because my wife and
I do have a an address there when our
time is up and
uh I'm sure Steve remembers when he came
home
there was no welcome met for a while so
I thank you it's an honor to do it sir
thanks
representative catch chorus
situation if you had a veteran buried in
your cemetery and they and the family
wanted to remove them and put them in
their Hometown how do you go about that
to have a veteran removed from the
cemetery we we do do disen tournaments
from time to time usually uh folks so
just like most any Cemetery somebody
wants to remove a veteran from our
Veteran Cemetery we don't actually do
the work they have to hire a funeral
home to transport unless it's cremated
remains right um so cremated remains
they just call us and we We There is a
fee for disinterment We disinter The
Remains hand them back to the family and
they can take them wherever they want to
so
um I'll give you an example a gentleman
used to come to the cemetery all the
time great guy
um he moved to Maine and so he took his
spouse she was cremated we disinterred
her and he took her up to the main State
Veteran Cemetery and he had her intern
there so what is the process you have to
go through
go to your office and what yeah you just
have to put in a request and then like I
said there's a fee just call us and
we'll take care of it it's usually not a
problem I will I will tell you one other
thing though
um in 2019 we put in pre-placed Auto
barrel of containers so the the the
concrete Vault that caskets go in are
already under the ground
this has been a very important because
it saves veterans the money of having to
purchase that Vault I will say we've had
not had anybody asked to disinter
somebody from there
um and I honestly don't know how we
would do that because we have
disinterred folks that are in
in individual Burial Vaults the the
funeral the The Vault company just comes
in and they lift the whole Vault out and
they take the Vault with the casket in
it away on a on a truck
um I don't know how we do it I don't
know if we could do it in our in the
pre-placed um that wouldn't be a
I wouldn't want to do that to be honest
with you but if it happens I'll figure
it out bye thank you for the information
yeah you're welcome
other questions
uh Sean uh so go ahead person Rollins
yes thank you Sean uh
and for the am I on now okay I'm gonna
ask this question for the Freshman
members here you talked about doing the
wreaths the first Saturday in December
could you expound on the cleanup day
roughly when we do that the spring
cleanup and the fall cleanup at what
time of the year we do that and what
that's all about sure as many hands make
light work amen to that
um
yes sir so we take the wreaths down the
first Saturday in January that's not a
holiday so this year it happened to be
on January 7th which would be the latest
that we would do it uh and that's you
this year was like world record time we
had about 2 500 wreaths that we put out
and uh probably took 30 minutes
um we had so many people that over a
hundred people came to volunteer and the
breeze came down we have a pretty good
little process that goes honestly the
same thing's true when we put out the
Reeves we have so many volunteers this
year we had to be close to a thousand
people that were there
um the parking is always really
difficult great thanks to the boscoin
police department and the Merrimack
County Sheriff because they come out and
helped control traffic because that's my
number one concern is that somebody
would ever get hurt
um you know out on Route three
um the memorial walkway cleanup happens
typically at the end of April is
sponsored by Rolling Thunder of New
Hampshire and then we also the Air Force
Academy Association of graduates and the
gold star families at the same day they
help they clean headstones so that
usually happens on a Sunday morning at
the end of April it always kind of
depends on the weather and we kind of
coordinate that and then we do another
cleanup headstone cleaning and walkway
cleanup with the same groups the right
the weekend before Veterans Day to make
sure the walkway is looking good
um we back I don't want to open up a can
of worms but back in the day we used we
do we do not do a Veterans Day service
at the veterans cemetery
um anymore we did back in the day but we
no longer do and the reason for that is
we want folks out in their communities
um because there's communities do all
kinds of events schools do events and we
wanted folks going there we didn't want
to be competing we never want to compete
with any other organization that's
trying to honor veterans which is the
reason that we do our Memorial Day on
May 30th at 11 o'clock we've staked that
out and so that everybody knows and so
that if they want to do it at their
school in their Town we're not competing
against that and so that's kind of one
of the things we always take into
account did I answer your question sir
yeah
oh
I just like to commend you on what a
great job you people do with such a
small staff that Cemetery for those
who've not been there before is
absolutely immaculate it reminds you of
Arlington and I would like to recommend
to any of the other members here that
haven't been down take a ride down there
sometime mark it on your calendar to do
the resacross America you better get
there early because so many people show
up to do that that sometimes you have to
shut the traffic off it is something
that you will never forget it's a great
feeling and for me every year I do it
what it really impresses me is the
parents that bring their children to
teach their children what this is all
about yeah absolutely and thank you for
doing an absolutely wonderful wonderful
job down there thanks sir it's our honor
to do it we couldn't do it without all
the volunteers and all the support that
you all give us but what I tell folks is
our veterans and their families they
earned it they they earned this right
for us to to take care of this place and
look good and I'm really proud that we
live in a state that really puts its
money where its mouth is it's time where
its mouth is I mean I I'm always getting
the support that I need I do want to
encourage you if you want to come let me
know when you stop in I'm happy to chat
with you to give you a little tour
around the cemetery and talk about
things in more detail as you can tell
I'm proud of the job that I have in the
cemetery that we have so thank you sir
thanks
other questions for the cemetery
director Sean buck
uh seen on a quick comment from me uh
Sean and to Echo representative Rollins
uh comments
um wonderful wonderful beautiful
facility my brother's remains are there
I guess I have a reservation there hope
don't I don't want to use it for a while
hopefully
um representative Kerry uh is a
representative for Bosco and of course
uh we're all resources for you ping me
anytime and we may we'll May ping we'll
pick some of you uh as well as we work
together to uh do the best we can for
people representative Alvin C uh is a
new rep uh vascoin is in his floaterial
district as well he's a Vietnam era
Naval veteran FYI uh I was going to ask
you about the spouse piece of it but you
touched on that a lot of folks don't
realize that spouses uh many spouses are
there now
um somebody pointed out once so there
was a veteran who was a widower he
remarried and he ended up uh spending
eternity with both of his wives does
that happen in well so let me I think
that's a good point
um I like to tell people the spouse is
eligible
through the veteran so it was as long as
they're married when either one of them
passes
the spouse can be interred at the
cemetery first a lot of people have that
notion that the veteran has to be the
first not true and in honesty the spouse
can be buried there and the veteran
doesn't have to come the spouse has
earned the spot just like the veteran
and to answer your question if the
veteran if the spouse passes and the
veteran remarries that new spouse is
also eligible so yes that can happen
um generally they wouldn't all be in the
same
plot but that could happen
um but I generally one wouldn't want
that you know but yeah we can we honor I
think it's important to understand that
we honor families I mean it's not easy
to be married to a veteran or an active
dirty member or anybody else and so we
think it's important that we honor them
as well uh and the last thing I'll
mention dependence people ask this
question all the time children
children of veterans can be eligible if
they're minors if they're still in
college
or if they have a permanent disability
that does not ever allow them to live on
their own
um so you know if they have some sort of
disability that they have to live with
the parents or they have to live in a
special cause they would be eligible
um as well so if there's ever questions
just call and ask we'll answer your
questions and I never tells
anybody who's had anything to do with
the military haven't talked to us and
apply don't self-select out let us tell
you whether you're eligible or not we
that's what we get paid to do
sanction I did not realize the uh the
the child the dependent or the child
piece of this that's new to me that's
great new information other questions
yes right here uh representative gagne
thank you thank you for your Indulgence
uh
the proof of service that's the DD214 is
that correct
yes typically it is sometimes so members
of the garden reserves the only DD214
sometimes they have is from basic
training so it's not enough
um so from the guards NGB 22
um for the reserves honestly the
reserves is the most difficult paperwork
and we've we we say bring us anything
that you have and you know sometimes
it's drill roll sometimes it's discharge
certificates whatever but typically
DD214 that's the easiest the reason I
was asking is the Freshman members some
of them who may not have
service members and now that they are in
Veterans Affairs that somebody would ask
me oh you're in that committee well how
do I do this thus and so so the simplest
one is the dd240 absolutely and our
application is on our website it's a
it's at the cemetery we have hard copies
just got a whole bunch of new ones
picked them up this week
um so yeah absolutely and again if any
of your constituents have questions just
point them to me I mean anything about
the Veteran Cemetery you don't have to
bother this busy man here just to send
them straight to me and I'm sure he
doesn't mind that
other questions
well he's your thank you thank you Sean
May 30th uh 11 o'clock May see you there
May 30th 11 o'clock I support the May
30th thing May 30 is my birthday and and
I was I always I always preferred when I
was a holiday uh but we've gotten away
from that but every seven years it's May
30th again so it works like a champ
right for that thank you Sean thanks sir
and intercommittee members our last week
will be uh Bill gadro the division of
veteran services
good morning chairman and the members of
committee again Bill gadrillo division
of Veterans Services
um in the era of introductions I I as
well am a vet a resident of the State of
New Hampshire I grew up in New Hampshire
I graduated and uh and joined the Navy
from where where New Hampshire I spent
30 years on active duty retired in 2016
and in 2017 I became a veteran service
officer for the for the division of
veteran services and by August I was
made the director of the agency
um I absolutely love my job I love what
I do I used to tell people when I
retired from the Navy I would do another
30 years tomorrow if they allowed me and
then I've got this job and there's no
way I'd go back this is just way too
important and this is just it's a
phenomenal job and I'm very appreciative
that I have this job what we do at
division of Veterans Services our
mission is we help veterans and their
families secure the benefits that they
have earned through their service in the
military we focus mostly on on
compensation disability compensation
with the VA and primarily reason why we
focus on that is because for a lot of
the other benefits that you receive from
the Veterans Administration they have
advocates for you so if you're looking
for Education if you pick up the phone
and dial the 1-800 number there will be
somebody on the other in the line who
will answer those questions about
education and hopefully there'll be a
smile in that in that conversation the
same thing goes for home loan guarantees
uh and for vocal rehab but when you
start talking about disability
compensation because you're filing a
claim against the VA that's where the
conversation ends and they tell you you
need an advocate because they're not
going to tell you how to win a claim
against them
so that's where we come in and we're not
the only uh agency that we're not the
only ones doing this the American Legion
the VFW the DAV they also have service
officers and at the end of the day
it doesn't matter to me who you go see
we don't compete against each other we
have about a hundred thousand veterans
in the state of New Hampshire and only
about 20 people doing what we do so
there's plenty of clients there's plenty
of work to be done uh if John Barrett if
you were told John Barrett's a guy to go
see what the VFW please go see John he's
an amazing Service Officer he's been
doing it for a lot of years we are your
state representatives so I work for the
governor
um we do it a little differently than
they do so for the national uh for the
the VFW the American Legion the DAV they
only have one service officer for the
entire State they may have Post Service
officers but those people just really
just kind of take your paperwork and
hand them over to the the national
service officers I have seven service
officers I have a much larger staff and
my service officers are strategically
located throughout the state whereas if
you want to go to the other
organizations they're in Manchester so
if you live up in the North Country you
have to drive down to Manchester to see
uh John Barrett so my service officers
are located in Nashua I have a service
officer out in Keene Portsmouth I have
two in Manchester because obviously
Manchester is a large area and I have
two in Concord that share time with in
Concord and up also up in the North
Country to include Littleton Berlin
Conway and and Groveton so we are all
over the state literally
I am all over the state I start off as a
vso which I think was an amazing part of
my progression to be the director
because I understand what it takes to be
a vso and I still do vso work today in
fact I was up in Conway yesterday
meeting with clients and that's what we
do we meet with veterans and we help
them through this VA process
my job in the Navy was a foreign
Communications intelligence analyst and
I thought I was a smart guy until I sat
down to do my first claim and it was
just no way no way I think veterans
should be having to do this on their own
so we advocate for them in that process
so we meet with them out at these
locations and we sit down with them for
about an hour and we hear what they have
to say and we help them in the process
of submitting that claim and it will be
a cradle to grave approach to the claim
so we can start with the initial claim
for compensation all the way up to
assisting a spouse with potentially
receiving survivors benefits so we
helped through the entire process to
include increases when disabilities tend
to get worse
um as you can see from the numbers
approximately we have about 220
appointments that we that we held every
month that's the seven service officers
split between the seven service officers
we help uh bring in about 93 million
dollars a year into the pockets of
veterans that's through the combination
of veterans uh disability compensation
veterans pension and also uh uh
survivors benefits so between those
three pots there's about 93 million
dollars that's coming from the VA into
the pockets of veterans
um and the average time right now the VA
is taking to process a claim is about
157 days and so just to help people
understand that not 157 days because
they've established that as their
process it's 157 days because they have
so many people in the system
um and there's so many people looking
for benefits and they're not they don't
just live in New Hampshire they live all
over the country so right now it's 157
days we do what we can to make that from
our perspective as easy as possible and
that is to work with the veteran to make
sure they have all the evidence and
everything they need to process that
claim
additionally we also help them with
state benefits we help also help them
understand state benefits I get calls
all the time from from state legislators
and from constituents of yours asking
about property tax credits I help them
understand how that works
um and at the end of the day I may not
be able to help your veterans with
everything but I think I would be a good
place to start if your veteran has
questions not necessarily to call the
agency to get an appointment but you can
call me and I will do what I what I can
to answer their questions
uh you have on your paper it has my name
it has my phone number and it has my
email email is really honestly the best
way to get a hold of me because I am in
and out of the office constantly uh but
if you're going to call me I wouldn't
recommend that number that you have on
your paper I would recommend contacting
me via my work cell and I won't mind
giving that to you now or I can provide
that to you somebody later but it's 603
eight five one
seven five five
I may not be able to answer you right
away
um I will get back to you uh at least
within the you know within a day or two
uh unless I'm on vacation
um and we do uh provide some other
services uh we do have the at least the
office provides some additional Services
we do have the
uh the
decal program so the state of New
Hampshire a few years ago decided uh
that they wanted to do a decal program
for license plates
so I guess some some snowbirds driving
down saw some other states that had
special decals on license plates and
they were like hey we need some of those
so the state of New Hampshire does that
as well
um the way it works is if you're a
veteran you go purchase the plate from
DMV and then you have to come to us to
get your decal and the decals that we
provide currently are service decals so
we have a decal for Army Navy Air Force
Marines Coast Guard and we also have the
space force we've created and gotten
that
and then we also have Medals of Valor
currently I guess there's some
legislation coming forward that will
potentially add some additional stickers
or decals but right now we do Medals of
Valor so we're talking
Medal of Honor bronze star with v Silver
Star Navy cross so we provide a lot of
those metals of Valor so that's
primarily what we do and that's pending
any questions that's my presentation
representative Kerry
one of the things you mentioned was the
property tax credit for veterans and
don't I understand the New Hampshire
legislature made a little change in
those credits so every town needs to
reaffirm their veterans property tax
credits both you know disabled veterans
as well as all veterans credit uh yes
representative so what the state did is
they changed and added active duty to
the conversation so prior to this the
only active duty that would get the
opportunity for a property tax credit
would be those that were currently
deployed on active duty in a combat area
well the law has changed and now act the
a recruiter who's here in New Hampshire
serving on active duty can now get a
property tax credit
um but but again as you stated the they
did change the law because they changed
the law now all the cities and states
have to reconfirm
not the standard tax credit they have to
reconfirm the all veterans tax credit
which is enabling legislation that each
Town gets to decide whether or not they
want to push forward
so
the questions for uh yes representative
representative O'Neill
um I had a meeting with a client the
other day excuse me I do estate planning
so we run into the property tax issue
here and there as well and one of the
questions that she had asked was so her
husband is deceased he was a veteran she
was receiving the property tax credit
um but she recently remarried and was
told that she would lose it at this
point is that is that accurate and that
is accurate um and I will stay for the
from the perspect of the VA that happens
as well so when you divorce a veteran
you divorce the VA uh you divorce
veterans benefits when your veteran
passes away you get to keep those
benefits until you remarry unless of
course you remarry a veteran then you
retain or you gain back the same
benefits so and the state works the same
way
great question other questions
uh representative Charlotte
well first of all thank you for what
you're doing it's so important and uh
especially to all our veterans and thank
you the question I had is I know years
ago New Hampshire had a federal veterans
Service Officer
um is that position still
build in New Hampshire or is
so I I've never heard of a federal uh
vso and that's primarily because I don't
believe a vso doesn't do advocations so
there was a there was a gentleman that
worked at the VA hospital in Manchester
his name was Beauregard and he worked
for the VA
that could be what I was thinking a lot
of people thought Beau was a uh was a
vso but he really honestly was just
taking paperwork he goes okay he can't
again as an employee for the VA he can't
advocate for veterans he can take
paperwork tell veterans what they need
but if a veteran has a question what do
you think I should do one they can't
suggest that that's where we come in
great thank you for letting me know that
the questions
saying none Bill I just want to thank
you again as uh representative shurliff
just said for all that you do I know I
have your name in my list of people
go-to people
um early we talked about a the latest
directory when that uh comes out for all
the different areas and in the veterans
world uh so that you're not you know the
Clearinghouse for there are some
questions that don't need to go to you
that we want to send them to the uh
better place when that directory is
ready if you could just alert me alert
us so we could get that latest
yes chairman um so I'll just let you
know that I do have I I have it in soft
copy and what I can do is I can just
email it to you I have your email
contact this way you can get it out to
everybody we do print it out and have it
uh New Hampshire employment security
helps us with that we actually partnered
with them to create the resource
directory and keep in mind it's not a
end-all be-all uh what you're not going
to find in there is you're not going to
probably find you're not gonna find
501c's you're not going to find the uh
you know the charitable organizations or
the philanthropic organizations that are
out there providing Services as well
right we can't forget those
organizations what mostly you'll find
the resource directory is state level
resources you know like Employment
Security and the devops that they have
there to help veterans with employment
uh it'll be things like mental health
and the different things that are
available for mental health in for
veterans in the state of New Hampshire
so that's really what you're going to
find the resource guide so we'll all
provide that but again what I will say
uh chairman is don't hesitate to call
you don't have to worry about whether or
not Bill's too busy and I will and I
will get back to you thanks if you could
push that info to me then I'll push it
out to the committee and elsewhere it'll
be great to get that and representative
Rollins
quick question do you have any business
guides on you I do actually have some
business cards on me I don't have a lot
but I do have some I would like to get
one is there anybody else here that
would like a business card
well I'll leave what I have believe what
you have all right leave them with me
thank you thank you thank you represent
Rollins and uh I will point out I think
that the committee hearings here in the
house I've been to several this past
week and they are on YouTube I've gone
back to look at pieces of them I'm
thinking this is uh live or being
recorded uh forever uh so whoever's
watching this or there were people who
come back to look at pieces of this
later so uh all your testimony so to
speak or your your input will be out
there for people to uh uh fast forward
to we're fine and look at just FYI
anything else for Bill guedrow uh
General uh sorry I have two Alibis
um L by number one is just deployment so
for the incoming refreshment
Representatives um the deployments and
how to read a service members uniform so
generally in the Army the patch to your
left hand side is the unit you're
currently are currently in so if you see
someone Supermarket the patch on your
right side is your sort of combat
deployment patch I just want to make
sure everyone sort of understands that
and uh speaking of deployments at any
given time New Hampshire National Guard
has a significant number of service
members deployed so right now we have
300 120 are in the Middle East 170 are
on the Southwest border and we have
onesie twosies in Europe Japan Cuba if
there's a country we probably have a
service member overseas
the next thing is when the 120 come back
from the Middle East we ship off another
280 to the Middle East and then we'll
ship off in later in the summer our
cyber unit to the national capital
region so we're busy we're always busy
and so when you think about those
deployments that's 9 to 12 months at a
service member is leaving both this
family as an employer just want to make
sure you understand that like
um
your business is steady it hasn't really
slowed down and so we just can't keep
doing what we need to do in defense of
our nation uh second Alibi is when you
look at legislative initiatives it's all
the sheets in here you'll see two that
we would uh well obviously request for a
favorable opinion of them and they both
have to deal with filling our formations
and I don't remember the house bill
numbers were off the top of my head but
generally speaking you might see these
two in separate uh bills one is um we're
both a family business and a referral
business eighty percent of new recruits
come from a military family and also
it's a word of mouth business right so
just like state government and some
employers we are currently offering a
500 referral bonus to any service member
below the rank of the captain that
recommends someone for military service
in New Hampshire National Guard we're
trying to increase that to a thousand
dollars I've been told by today's
generation uh 500 is a ashrae change in
your car I thought that was a big deal
when I was a kid apparently nowadays
it's not so trying to go from 500 to a
thousand and always remember there's two
levers trying to get the people to come
in and trying to retain the people you
currently have and a sessions and
retention that's in a sessions tool the
retention tool is
uh community college system of New
Hampshire was spectacular last session
we expanded our tuition waiver program
that you can now transfer to your spouse
your common phrase is the service member
of volunteers but the family of the
spouse gets drafted so we're expanding
that program now to the university
system of New Hampshire
so if a soldier Airman reenlists Beyond
six years either or he or she or their
spouse can now transfer that benefit to
allow he or she the spouse to take
classes at the community college and now
the university system of New Hampshire
so that's a retention tool so I just you
know want to let you know those are two
significant uh bills for us and we just
hopefully look upon your uh you know
favorable position on it
a general your last comment on the
transfer of education benefits uh I know
the GI bill on the national level in
fact I transferred some of my benefits
to a daughter so but this is a state
program correct yes uh yes yes and it's
only for your spouse
okay thanks for clarifying that uh great
presentation General Alibis I I've used
some in the rifle range myself uh any
more Alibis
um so that's it for our subjective
questions
uh he has a suicide statistics if you
want them now man
thank you for having me back up and
quickly uh the data that I that I have
uh representative Kerry is from the VA
and it's as of 2020. there was 36
veteran suicides in 2020. uh less than
10 of those were females
15 of those was less than lethal means
and the other uh
sorry in the 21 were firearm related
deaths
and as soon as I have more information
more current information from the VA I
can forward it to this committee
and uh to uh representative Rollins
questions about facilities that house
veterans I forgot there was one in
Plymouth called Boulder point
you're welcome thank you represent
pimani
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Jones I have one question for you
um I know was that a uh a state uh
number that you gave us from New
Hampshire uh yes that is uh it is for
State of New Hampshire and I just want
to point out the VA says that the uh the
amount of Veteran suicide for 2020 was
significantly higher than the national
veteran suicide rate
follow up go ahead 22 kill can you
explain uh that uh
opt that confirm if you know about it
22kill.com
uh no I I'm not familiar with that okay
I can brief a little bit that's a
country uh Nationwide
oh I'm sorry that's a nation uh survey
and they add they took an average of 22
veterans uh commit suicide per day
uh in in the country and um
they I know it's gone up or down last
three years I think that one I had was
2018 maybe but you can go to the website
22kill.com and get information on that
Nationwide it is very informative so
that's all thank you again I'm new in my
position so I'm learning quite a lot
thank you for your time
yes uh representative Lloyd hi thank you
um I actually just wanted to say hi and
um do you have contact information for
um for yourself
um I'm
very interested in the community
programs that we have to offer veterans
um specifically to try to help the
suicide rate go down I recently read an
article that we were kind of one of the
top states for veteran suicide rates
um so I don't want to see that continue
I can leave in my business card and you
can also contact us with the material
that was provided today thank you very
much welcome
last call
uh General thank you wonderful excellent
presentation uh look forward to staying
in touch we have uh and I know Kevin so
we've got some bills coming up next week
and the week after and we'll get into
that brief in a bit but thank you so
much for your time
uh thank you sir and then committee
thank you committee members
okay next up at uh 10 45 and it's uh 10
51 so we're close to being on time which
is a veterans uh committee we're going
to try to be real good at uh svac I see
uh Paul Lloyd is in the house
uh among others from the state veterans
advisory committee I think I get that
right
so Paul if you don't mind uh talking to
us uh tell us about uh svac I attended a
meeting recently there's a lot of people
and pieces to that so uh welcome
thank you
um Kevin's going to come up with us he
wrote the brief so I don't I don't want
to steal his Thunder
but for the for the record my name is
Paul Lloyd I am the chairman of the
state veterans advisory committee
I'm also the state adjutant for New
Hampshire VFW
and the chairman of the board of
managers at the veterans home
I'm also the quartermaster for the local
post that uh representative Charlotte
and Moffett are members of
I'm a Navy veteran
I started out so the Army Navy games
unique for me because I started out in
the Army in the National Guard and then
went into the Navy so regardless uh I'm
a winner
Kevin where you going
here you go sir
anyone see you then are you I'm done
you're done okay
all right um
Mr chairman ladies and gentlemen of the
committee uh my name is Kevin Grady uh
by way of introduction uh to what I do
and and everything I'll like everybody
else I'll give you a little bit about my
my background I mostly I was a son of a
military officer in the Air Force
bounced around the country settled in
Colorado Springs
graduate from the Air Force Academy was
an active duty Air Force officer for 25
years mostly as a fighter pilot flying
f-15s I tend to look at things through
that little narrow fighter pilot lens
sometimes
um my last assignment was sitting behind
a big steel desk in Germany which you
want a fighter pilot to sit behind a
desk the only thing that matters is the
location of the desk I'd rather be the
snow removal officer over there than the
chief of staff in the Pentagon believe
me
um so then I got tired of sitting behind
a desk realized that you know they're
not going to let the old man fly f-15s
anymore flew 737s for United for about
five and a half years got tired of being
gone literally all the time so I opened
up the Air Force Junior ROTC program
down at Auburn High School in Hudson
where I uh I taught for 11 years in a
public high school and then after that I
retired retired retired my wife makes me
say it three times so that I don't take
another job I'm sure some of you can
relate to that I have been with the
state veterans advisory committee now as
a a member of the Air Force Association
which is now the air and space forces
Association since 2006 we've been around
since 2002 and you have the handout
there with our history
I became the legislative chair
um in 2016. some of you may have if
you've been around the the uh the house
a while you some of you may have
remembered Ed Josephson in this position
before me and when Ed passed away in
2016 since Ed also represented the Air
Force Association it it passed to me to
be the legislative chair and what I do
generally is when the when the
legislative calendar you know when they
when we start seeing the lsrs in the
fall I scrub all of them and try and
figure out which ones have veteran
impact and then we take a vote at our
committee meeting about whether we
support or oppose or some of them would
just like to sit like a fly on the wall
and we call it follow we're going to go
and see see which way the wind is
blowing we do that sometimes on bills
and then I go and I tell you what it is
that that we think and I'll be here next
Friday there's three bills and I thank
the chairman so much for uh for
scheduling all the bills that are going
to come to your committee that we're
following this year are all on the same
day love that so so thank you sir for
doing that for us
um as far as who we are and what we do
we meet the first Tuesday of every month
from January to June and September to
December
we usually meet at five o'clock at the
cross training center in Pembroke that
some of you may have been there it's
wonderful facility sometimes we Veer off
and we go to the veterans home up in
Laconia and we have a meeting up there
once a year that's been a little harder
to do with coven so you know we we we're
very respectful of those kind of
protocols up there and
[Music]
I want to give you an idea of kind of
what a typical meeting looks like for us
and you know we we have guest speakers
that come in and uh and tell us about
what they're doing to help veterans or
they solicit our help getting started or
they solicit our help in figuring out
the right place to go uh to get things
done uh there then we hear from the VA
medical centers Kevin Forrest is usually
there when we used to do this by Zoom Dr
bash open in White River Junction
Junction would appear and tell us what's
going on over there and with the sea box
we have in the state
um and then then we have the all of the
Departments you just heard from kind of
tell us what they're what they're
thinking and what they're working on the
commandant of the veterans uh the
Veterans Home comes and tells us about
how things are are going up there uh and
then you know I I kind of keep up with
what we're doing uh of a legislative uh
nature here the other thing we do we
actually have a representative from the
governor and we have a representative
from all of our Congressional
Representatives that attend this meeting
and their their purpose is literally
twofold one number one they're reporting
back to their bosses of what we're
talking about and then they're also
there as a to tell us what their bosses
are working on that have better an
impact in Washington D.C so it's great
we have access to those folks
all the time and I've been doing this
now for this is my 17th year doing this
and I'll tell you I've I've seen I've
worked with Democrats I've worked with
Republicans but no one works harder for
the State of New Hampshire than our
Congressional Delegation and their and
their reps nobody and it doesn't matter
what party those people work extremely
hard for all of you and and every time
every time I get the chance to say thank
you to I do
um
you are certainly welcome to join us
anytime you you'd like to you in with
the handout there you've got Paul's
email address that the New Hampshire
nhsvac.chair gmail.com anytime you want
to come and talk to us you can
um
one of the things that we do we're
really about three things that we do
very very well one is we are literally
an information Clearinghouse
Paul gets a lot of emails I'll tell you
that from all kinds of places and he
passes them to us and we in turn because
we're a member we're 20 member
organizations we shotgun that out to all
of our folks and some of us some of you
who are veterans in this room know what
I'm talking about you're represented you
you represent more than one organization
I represent you know the Air Force
Association on state veterans advisory
committee but I'm also the the uh flight
captain for the dedelions chapter of
military aviators I'm also on the you
know the board for the New Hampshire
Association of graduates of the Air
Force Academy so and and I'm also an
admissions liaison counselor for the Air
Force Academy so I've got I see I have a
lot of different constituencies that I
can pass information to and I typically
do
um the other thing that that we are is
kind of a a a huge room full of
corporate knowledge about stuff about
especially stuff about how to help
veterans and I'll give you sort of a
little bit of a success story on that
front about six or seven years ago I
can't remember probably about six years
ago Governor sununu right after he was
re-elected for the for the first time
came to see us
and he talked to us for about five
minutes and then he looked up and he
said if I have a veteran that has a
problem
where do I send them
and we all looked at each other and we
kind of acknowledged you know the answer
is probably somewhere in this room but
we don't really have a single belly
button point of contact that we can
point people to that that you know that
can get this done and what that
precipitated that visit started the
process that has produced what you have
today in the department of military uh
Affairs and Veterans Services so those
those things you know having the
governor come and ask us a question we
couldn't answer was in fact pretty
important to getting getting better
stuff done for our veterans
um you know we also have access to the
to the Congressional Delegation
um every every meeting somebody asks a
question of one of our Congressional
reps about something and then and that
answer gets back to all of us so that's
a great thing the last thing I'll close
with and I'll let Paul or or this
handsome gentleman here to my left is
the was the is uh Commander Dave Kinney
he was the uh chair of the state
veterans advisory committee before Paul
I'll let them have a chance to speak if
you want here's how you can help us
my least favorite thing in the entire
world is to go and testify at a hearing
about a bill that's supposed to help
veterans that we don't support that we
oppose that's that's my least favorite
thing in the whole world okay so if
you're going to to file a bill to help
veterans
then you know we're a resource that you
can use we'll help you with the language
we will maybe we've had the corporate
history that could tell you well this
was tried before and here's what
happened on it when it happened before
we maybe we may have that kind of
expertise that can help you out as well
I I had a moment last year when I was
testifying at a bill that we did not
support where a senator actually looked
at me and said well did you talk to the
bill sponsor about this bill before you
uh decided you're going to oppose it
okay lesson learned so now this this
year and going forward every time a bill
goes in that we don't that we are not
going to support I reach out I'm going
to reach out to that bill sponsor and
say I'm sorry but we don't support your
bill you know
you have the opportunity to to use us as
a resource if you are putting out a bill
and we don't understand what it's about
come talk to us come talk to us on
Tuesday night Paul will absolutely put
you on the schedule and and we we can
accommodate we know you you folks are
busy people you know we can put you on
right at the beginning and you can zip
in and zip out you know tell us what you
need to know and and then get on with
your day
so unless there are any questions for me
I'm I I'd be more than or or Paul or
or Commander Kenny Dave
yes representative Rollins
yes sir yes thank you Mr chairman yeah
quick question you said 20 members could
you give us a rundown of what those
members are what organizations they come
from they're at the bottom of your
handout right there at the bottom of the
handout okay I didn't see it thank you
those are the 20 members that we have uh
right right currently those are the 20
voting members voting members right
there are other groups that come in and
attend the meeting okay I didn't get a
chance to look at that I was asking that
more for the freshman and yes but thank
you yes sir it's right to you perfect
thank you
other questions
Mr Grady is a Air Force fighter pilot uh
have you seen either the Top Gun movies
yes sir I've I've seen them both yes sir
do you give them thumbs up or a thumbs
down
the second one is a little better than
the first one
um although I take I take
particular Umbridge to uh to Iran having
a fifth generation fighter that's gonna
fight those guys off sorry about the
spoiler alert if you have
take a little umbrance to that but the
the flying scenes are are fairly
realistic uh more so on the second one
than the first one
thank you Colonel great I figured that
you may have seen that uh yes sir uh
representative you have a question
[Laughter]
Kevin thanks so much and Paul uh and
Dave thanks for coming in
um and we'll see you next week next
Friday sir and uh look forward to that
and uh thanks again
thank you okay our final two presenters
uh we're a little bit now we're a little
we're five minutes behind schedule now
we're a little bit ahead of schedule uh
both Kevin and Kimberly Kevin Forrest in
the veterans hospital and uh Kimberly
McKay from the veterans home both are
out of the meetings they're going to be
here about 11 30 or 11 45. uh and
they'll be our last two and they'll both
be here as soon as they can so I I want
to have a brief recess until 11 well
until 11 30 but before we do that uh
representative Judy is in the house and
before you get here representative we
did a whip around where people uh just
uh told us a little bit about who they
are where they're from and if you
wouldn't mind uh doing the same and just
uh tell us uh who you are where you're
from and and uh anything else you'd like
to add
laughs no I'm not good to speak French
you have 20 minutes if you need it
yes uh my name is Jean Judy uh I am okay
I am representing uh what three in
Manchester this the 23 now and uh I be
this is my uh
item
and I was an Edna for 2005.
but because of my wife uh sickness so
that's why I changed and to become a
veteran now
and uh
I have good experience in uh Edna
so if uh anyone needs some information
about Edna
uh I can provide it yes and originally I
come from Haiti
I speak French I speak Korean
is a long time friends
it was as if short left is a long time
when I have great respect for them
and uh Happy New Year to everyone
and I'm glad I leave a message for you
in French I don't know if you hear that
uh we I did hear that and I did speak to
you in French on francaise and Edna I
was at just a brief comment but uh uh
bienvenue yeah
foreign
didn't allow me to at least address your
committee ever so quickly oh Steve Greco
portion of that or oh save perfect time
yeah right if so I don't want to keep
all of these people from a break
would you prefer to take your break and
then I would address you no no we'd like
to hear from you and then we'll uh take
that break ready spot please
thank you so much thank you
thank you thank you all
I will make my comments great
baseball first and foreign let me thank
all of you
and say Mr President of Fort Smith New
Hampshire for your service to our great
branch of faith
we would normally thank me for my
service I'd like to thank all of Youth
for your service because you're worth it
this country is working so I am the
friend am I supposed to be talking to
this so you can tell yes so sit down
right yes please thank you there you go
I will literally make this brief
I'm the only person that doesn't get a
wingman isn't that interesting is an Air
Force guy
I also can't see the two sides my name
is Steve Greco I am the President of the
National Guard Association of New
Hampshire I really wish I could see you
guys
note to self move these speakers
I
was an Air Force veteran and a member of
the New Hampshire Air National Guard so
I served seven years I went to Pilot
training with United States Air Force
and then got out because I had friends
who flew for this Guard unit I came to
peas and served the remainder of my
total of 30 years of military service
at the completion of my term and
retiring in 2009 then the accident
General Bill Riddell said hey why don't
you do a little pro bono work there Mr
smartypants and go be the president of
the National Guard Association of New
Hampshire to which I said absolutely
because almost everything that has ever
been really kind of given to me that's
including my wife all the great things
in life have come from my association
with this Air Guard unit and this
National Guard
I am also on the board of directors and
so your front page uh has the two
associations the National Guard
Association in the United States is a is
literally the legislative uh entity that
fights for legislation for the Army and
Air National Guard and their website is
there I'm not about to sit and tell you
all the different things they do but
it's an association of associations 54
states and territories of which we are
one of them
and so their mission and vision
statement is there more importantly the
one below it is our association our
mission statement the three big words
that I always like to say to people to
support past present and future right so
the people are veterans the people that
are currently serving and the people
that will serve just as the actions
General said we're always recruiting for
that next person who's going to become
the adjective General and finally
relevance Readiness modernization and
quality of life so that's really our
Mantra that's what we do and we do work
with the Congressional Delegation
because there is a legislative side to
our association and there's also a
philanthropic side we use corporate
Partners here in the state of New
Hampshire and larger companies Service
Credit Union is a person that we work
with as well as Boeing Airbus and we
take those funds and then we distribute
them to our service men and women in
different forms and Fashions because as
you all well know it's the color of
money and you can't always necessarily
take money out of a military budget that
is supposed to be doing one thing and
support other things
so that's how I work with the adjective
General one-on-one to support those
local unit things that we do our website
is currently under construction so it's
not as robust as the National Guard
Association is but they are both we work
in together with our corporate Partners
as I say I was a pilot I was a
traditional Guardsman so I did this
part-time and of course as you all well
know with some of the places we've gone
and some of the places we have been and
everything from Desert Storm Desert
Shield all the way back we have been
busy a last thing that I did was in
Joint Force Headquarters work the KC 46
which gives you a lead-in to the next
page as you all well know Senator
Shaheen is now on her third third term
in the United States Senate she is on
the Senate armed services committee and
Senate Appropriations defense
subcommittee
she and us and we told the total New
Hampshire State of New Hampshire worked
very hard to get this kc-46 this KC 46
as you have already been briefed has a
big footprint because it unlike the old
airplane we that I flew that we flew is
in-flight air refuelable so when we talk
about the projection of air power across
the world that is one of those kind of
things that gets everybody's attention I
have sat out on the Airfield in Guam
when
b2s were landed strictly because they
were there to have the satellite fly
over and say hi we're here I mean our
ability to project air power and land
forces are making a difference
everywhere in the world and so for you
to support the people that support that
portion of our government and our
ability to keep peace is enormous which
is why once again I will thank you for
serving on this committee and in serving
for the things that we do
we as the attention Journal likes to say
uh fight way above our weight class here
in the state of New Hampshire and
Senator Shaheen is just one of many
examples of that number three and I'm
moving as quickly as I possibly can So
when you say well what do you do
legislatively like what is it that you
do I bet you a bunch of people who
didn't know what high Mars was until a
little bit ago until we sent some to
Ukraine so one of the things that we do
because we're trying to be relevant
right and we're trying to stay
concurrent with the United States Army
and Air Force this is a just a copy of
the resolution it sits on the nogus
website that was submitted by our own uh
entity and it has to do with high
Mobility artillery rocket system and
here's a perfect example the the
battalions in the Army are three by nine
we're going for two by eight and that's
two batteries and eight launch rocket
launches so here's one of those
resolutions that we that that was
supported by the state of New Hampshire
uh I'm also working with the action
General with some other initiatives but
here's a prime example of some of the
stuff that we do and finally the last
page of course is covid
and as you well know and that's the
beauty about people like uh
former Governor Shaheen because they are
the commander-in-chief of your New
Hampshire militia right the this this
thing called the Army and Air National
Guard goes all the way back right John
Stark Live Free or Die death is not the
greatest of evils right this goes this
goes all the way back to forming the
Commonwealth in Massachusetts and all
through the revolution this is your
ability this this National Guard
Association was formed by in 1878 by
Civil War officers who were looking for
benefits from the Carnage created by
that war and so that is what we do and
you'll notice that the National Guard is
one of those people that you can't
always call out right so you had you had
certain events where you just legally
can't call out the guard but there's a
bunch of stuff that you can and so when
your citizens our citizens call for Need
for either the ice storm or floods or
any of those they go on what's called
title 32 which is State active duty and
there commander-in-chief is your
Governor he or she commands those forces
under General
ities and then when we go up on the big
Wars Global Shield I've flown all that
stuff right I've I've been part of all
that stuff for all those many years I'm
on active duty
title 10 USC United States service code
and so this is what we try to do we try
to get this National Guard ready for
both of its very unique missions it can
be caught up onto active duty states of
emergency and during war and it can be
called by the state so so I thank you
I'll I'll end I'll end with one more
thing
and I wasn't going to go down this
because it's emotional but I'm also a
member of the peas uh honor guard
and you're right representative gagne we
we do try to say thank you and we we
have spent a long time as a country uh
getting ourselves never well but better
for the for what happened with the
return of our Vietnam veterans one of
the most poignant moments literally of
my military career was as a member of
the honor guard and we were
together when you put a full Honor Guard
together it's the firing party it's the
color guard it's the casket carry it's
the bugler and it's the OIC which
happened to be me that day and they had
recovered remains of a C-130 uh enlisted
member uh in a country over in that
region of the world where we used to
fight
and it just so happened that Rolling
Thunder that day was accompanying so
what we do is we all practice so that it
looks professional then we kind of Mill
around for a while until we get uh
notification that they're leaving the
funeral home on that particular day we
didn't need notification because you
could hear rolling thunder come in for
all those who do or do not know these
are motorcycle riders mostly Harley
Riders and as we gathered in our
respective positions I was standing
there on a sunny beautiful day it wasn't
at Bosque on but it was and the flags
were waving and I was reflecting on how
lucky I was to have a father who fought
in World War II and also be
a member of the honor guard and be in a
country where we are allowed to honor
our fallen service members and just to
hear them come in and to be there that
day is an experience I will never forget
so for those of you who have served I
thank you I thank you for your service
and for those of you who are now on this
committee thank you for your help
because you are making a big difference
in our state and you are carrying the
flag for all the way back to when uh
John Stark
was at the Battle of well Bennington
um
yeah
it's always my dad
so so anyway I I apologize for being a
late ad representative Moffett uh but
but anyway uh I have I do have business
cards not that I'm uh anybody that you
need or necessarily want to talk to but
if you ever do he has my uh yes my
contact information and and I apologize
for interrupting your break because I
took a lot more than five minutes I I
will I will not take questions unless
somebody has something burning I will
sit here in case during your break you
want to talk to me and if not thank you
for your time
Steve thank you so much for a wonderful
presentation for being here and a couple
things real quick and maybe some
questions uh uh I get married in
Bennington and we visited John Stark's
statue right after this ceremony that
not that you need to know that I know
when I saw you at svac I uh initially
mistook you for General mikolaidis so
that you have some flag officer uh uh
potential yes and I I appreciate that
right and my uh my last question comment
I know you're dealing on the federal
side and this of course is state federal
and Veterans
um so if we needed to get a hold of uh
Senator Shaheen's office you might be a
conduit for that possibly uh I actually
we do work with Congressional Delegation
I happen to know that evening that you
were sitting in front of me right behind
you as you well know with Senator
Shaheen's one of her staffers uh Chris
Scott so yeah yes we uh we we do have
those kind of connections with those
people and and we usually try to work
with their staffers whenever as I say
General mcliti says has his sights he's
a he is a man that I don't think sleeps
I I continue to ask his wife where do
you plug him what battery charger in
this house most adjectives in generals
are that way because they work so many
hours I mean they're they're in charge
of a multi-million dollar Enterprise I
mean on the civilian side they I mean
they're CEOs of the of and there's so
much going on you could talk to General
nicolaidis for hours about the different
things but anyway I've said to his wife
many times where do you plug them in and
then because he can only can he he can
only be so anyway we do work with the
I'm I'm the civilian equivalent of the
person that does legislative work uh in
in different areas mostly up on the
federal side uh for modernization of
equipment but I'm easy to find and and
yes we do have those contacts
representative
excellent any other questions at this
time yes represent Rollins yes not a
question uh but as a member of Rolling
Thunder is our honor to do those escorts
and we thank you for the service that
you give to us and making us a free
country and free people so we thank you
it's our way of paying back I I I'm
telling you that that sound when you're
standing in that I mean I'm the last as
you well know I'm the last person hence
this flag to a surviving spouse son
daughter whatever like like I I'll stop
with this when you lean over to give
that folded flag and there's people
weeping and there's people that are and
you give that to another person another
citizen of our United States and there
is that moment where you have your hands
and your white gloves and you give that
to them and they put their hands
sometimes on top of yours or on that
flag and there's that just one moment
where I swear to you time stops it just
stops and we can never ever ever stop
doing that honoring our veterans and we
can never ever stop doing what you are
all doing which is to make sure our
veterans and there's so many different
things that you all do and all the
different entities that you serve and
the people that you are are content
constituents and all the things we
better not ever lose sight of what we do
for our veterans because as George
Washington said I'll tell you how this
is all going to go by the way that we
treat the people that we current I mean
you know this is not exactly his quote
but but we're going to figure out how
well we are as a United States military
by how well we take care of the people
that are currently serving right
so so thank you God bless you all
anything else
thanks again Steve so we'll take 10
minutes like I said Kevin from the
hospital and Kimberly from the veterans
home both or other meetings I needed
here as soon as they can uh whoever gets
here first will listen to them first so
uh
will take 10 minutes and we'll see you
in 10. and thank you episode Judy for
your uh your intro
all right folks if you can hear me in
the hall uh another minute
T minus a minute
both Kevin and Kimberly are in the house
so we're good to go
it in another minute
well they can just uh show up and Float
a pink cars
thing I guess you weren't here last term
right uh during the cover thing there
was a way to sign up to testify remotely
but that's not right yep
[Music]
opportunity
for what
[Music]
we'll get started about uh a half a
minute
see if it works
Phyllis everybody got your love about me
that's it all right we're breaking up
I'm not breaking up that yeah
we have medical people here to testify
and I know some of our Representatives
uh occasionally need some medical uh
when a lawyer testifies sometimes they
get requests for free legal advice I
know you run into that and we have
medical people here so
um I want to welcome Uh Kevin for us and
and Kimberly McKay is on Deck thank you
for being here I know you both had other
meetings and so uh just want to take a
little bit of time starting with with
Kevin uh to talk to us about uh the
Veterans Hospital
good to go all right well good morning
and thank you so much for for the invite
I always you know love an opportunity to
educate you know certainly the the uh
the legislature the delegation and uh
and everybody about the services that we
provide at the Manchester VA and and you
know I'll say as a as a veteran and a
native of New Hampshire and somebody who
entered the Army from New Hampshire and
after I retired and and came back home
to me there's really no greater calling
than to be able to continue what I did
on active duty as an Army medical
service Corps officer and continue
serving you know veterans here in my
home state of New Hampshire and I said
that's what you know keeps me coming to
work every morning and coming through
the front door and it's just a wonderful
organization and great people that we
work with to take care of uh you know
our New Hampshire veterans so I um I
wasn't sure you know how many veterans
we have in the room or exposure to the
Manchester VA so I wanted to provide an
overview of of the of the services that
we provide a little bit about the
leadership team certainly the direction
uh that that we're going you know and
especially you know the last couple
years have been really tough with a
pandemic and a lot of things going on
but you know we persevere and and Forge
forward here and then uh you know maybe
cover a little bit of of the challenges
and things that we see so that so that
you know you know and and uh I look at
everybody as an advocate for helping
veterans here in New Hampshire you know
we provide the health care but you know
we work with so many Community Partners
you know whether we came up at the at
the state veterans home and others that
uh we can't do it alone and we depend
very really on a number of folks to uh
to take care of of veterans so so thank
you for uh you know invite here I I'll
start off
um you know we for demographics we serve
you know a little shy of a hundred
thousand veterans uh or a hundred
thousand veterans in New Hampshire here
we have about between 27 and 28 000
veterans are enrolled to the Manchester
VA there's another uh 10 000 veterans
that are enrolled to the VA up at White
River Junction for those veterans that
live up in the uh you know Hanover and
Lebanon area up there where it's closer
but we really is part of what we call
the North Market which includes Vermont
and New Hampshire really team up a lot
with White River to to provide care you
know they provide some levels of care
that we don't in Manchester so we work
work very very well with them
um I say that because you know there's
still a um a gap of of those folks that
are not enrolled now that doesn't mean
everybody is eligible for for health
care but you know of that other 35 to 40
000 veterans many are and we have you
know an aggressive Outreach team that
goes out and want to make sure that
veterans are
aware of their benefits and that we have
our doors open and if if uh you know we
can serve them whether it be their
health care or other things we want to
know that we want them to know that that
we are a resource to them and I'll say
you know it's been really good we have
an aggressive Outreach team and this
latest legislation of The Pact act which
is probably some of the most robust
legislation in in the last 30 years or
so has opened up eligibility for
veterans uh especially you know exposed
to different uh toxic exposures burn
pits things like that that perhaps
aren't eligible in in the past and so
we've really leveraged that to educate
veterans uh via you know town halls and
our media to get them to come in and
they've started coming in it was great I
did a a town hall back right before
Christmas and had uh you know oef oef
veterans uh from uh you know Iraq and
Afghanistan that had never stepped foot
into the EA and came to listen and and
you know enrolled I think you know even
eight people that night who really had
never intended on on walking him before
and uh you know I always told them that
that you know you may not need that
health care now but please you know
we're a resource and and being enrolled
and understanding those uh those
benefits now it's a lot easier to do it
up front than when you find out when you
do need them and then we have to go you
know through a lot of things with
eligibility so you know we continue to
um to move forward that I uh
when I when I opened town halls and and
speak to our new employees that come in
the Manchester VA I've had my my mission
statement or I call it my director's
intent from the time I was in the Army
but
I say what every day should look like
and for veterans you know I've got
veterans find it easy to get an
appointment when it works well for them
they enter our facility they're greeted
with dignity and respect and they leave
knowing they were well taken care of and
then those veterans tell other tell
other veterans to come get their care at
the Manchester VA and so you know as
complexes hospitals are I tell them
everybody knew coming in whether it's a
physician you know front line staff
whoever it is
if you keep that in your mind and try to
live up to that and make that happen
each and every day everything else will
fall into place and so that's you know
really my my vision for for a veteran
then likewise for staff
I say you know but every day what I want
staff to have every day look like is you
know Manchester VA employees can't wait
to come to work because they believe in
our mission they feel valued they're
part of a team and they get to do
Innovative things outside their normal
job description and so again you know we
have a lot of other ways that veterans
are for that staff are able to uh to get
involved in the hospital and that's what
keeps them fresh and keeps them you know
wanting to work there so I just I wanted
to say that because that's kind of what
drives me in the morning and when I get
down to to Really my uh
um uh you know that intent it just kind
of drives drives everything else
going back to so our array of facilities
so we certainly have the main facility
in in Manchester
an aging facility we are not a
full-service hospital we do have
inpatient care for long-term care
patients we have 41 beds with a census
of 11 uh right right now
but you know our primary services are
certainly a focus on Primary Care Mental
Health Suicide Prevention we have a
number of different Medical Specialties
and have been growing a lot over the
last couple years to include you know
Cardiology endocrinology and a lot of
those Medical Specialties we have a big
focus on pain management uh in keeping
veterans off opioids as part of their
their uh their pain programs we have a
growing surgical program
with three operating rooms and a
procedure room albeit although I will
say that if folks have watched the news
we had an unfortunate pipe break the
weekend of Thanksgiving which I'm
navigating my way through here now and
um uh I think it'll be we're targeting
mid-april of getting the or back open
we've got some some water mitigation and
things we need to do
um but I'll say is I think a credit to
our staff even after that pipe break
which took out three uh floors of the
hospital which is you know it's tough
out of seven to eight hundred
appointments that we do daily in there
even that Monday we did just over 600
and we were very fortunate to be able to
take every nook and cranny and clinical
area and move those places that were
impacted into those so
um but the surgical uh Suite um you know
is tough so we've been shifting Folks up
to White River Junction our sister
facility for surgeries and we also were
in negotiations right now with um uh
local private sector hospitals like we
had done before four or five years ago
to have agreements for or space and it's
in my interest to actually keep those
agreements going even after crisis
because with aging infrastructure I
think you never know when you need to
Pivot from a continuity of operations
standpoint and we all rely on each other
and and we certainly have during the
pandemic both us using the private
sector and them actually using uh and
asking us for for personnel help so I
would say the relationships are good in
the community of us us work talking
together we certainly have a big rehab
service and and a focus on on Whole
Health
so that's you know in in the main in the
main campus there we do have four
outlying community-based outpatient
clinics uh we have two over in the
Seacoast one that's
um uh nested with the Medical Group over
with the uh the air refueling wing on on
peas and so we're in their their medical
group and we've got a a small Clinic
over there and then we've got one of the
newer facilities up in Somersworth about
10 miles away uh uh when each of those
clinics has about 2500 veterans assigned
to them in the in the Seacoast area
then we have two clinics up north we've
got one north of here in Tilton uh where
we
offer
primary care and mental health and
certainly actually work with with Kim
here too at the state veterans home then
we have a a clinic up in Conway uh for
in the in the Mount Washington Valley
each of those community-based outpatient
clinics certainly a focus on Primary
Care Mental Health we have social work
embedded in there
um uh we one of our strategic objectives
is having medical Specialty Care go out
to these remote clinics instead of
having Manchester be the epicenter for
for everything you know it's tough in
Conway in the middle of the winter time
for somebody to come down you know
possibly for an appointment so we've had
our Specialists going out to those
clinics and we also have a huge Reliance
on Telehealth the VA actually Telehealth
in in the country so each of those
outline clinics has a Telehealth Hub
where you know perhaps somebody needs a
dermatology appointment and if it's
appropriate uh you know that veteran can
be at like that Conway clinic and speak
to our dermatologist and and uh and be
seen uh without without coming down to
the to the main facility so uh the
beauty of that in with the VA New
England Health Care system is uh we not
only have our own Specialists that help
augment that Hub we actually have all of
New England so it's feasible that you
know a veteran that might be up here in
the Tilton Clinic is speaking to a
nephrologist out of the VA in
Connecticut so it's it's really really a
powerful tool for us to be able to uh to
provide access to care that's really
tough and some of those more more remote
areas even even on the outside
so our strategic uh you know Direction
we continue to build a lot of
infrastructure I'll say you know one
main arm of ours is growing the
workforce and personnel and it's
certainly been tough over the last
couple years a lot of people have left
health care and not just in the VA and
it makes it you know very difficult
um you know for us so you know it's my
job and the leadership to make sure that
you know we have competitive salaries
we're able to uh I'll say you know
compete with the private sector but also
just make it attractive so you know
things like we've done student loan
repayment not only for recruiting but
even retaining staff that are that are
there a number of of salary surveys that
go up to Washington that we look at and
and uh
um to compete you know with the private
sector and and things have gone pretty
you know pretty well
um I think for us it's it's being able
to uh
um continue getting the word out and
recruiting and having people come in but
I think that the best thing that I've
seen you know the va's it's it's it's
different you know providing care in the
VA you know we have a lot of other
extender programs and I find that that
when um when staff come in uh the
relationship they have with veterans
it's really that calling that I talked
about that they enjoy you know
practicing medicine in that environment
and veterans are just very thankful you
know for for the care that they get so
certainly working with uh uh you know
growing the workforce and and
professional development from within the
other thing is expansion of services so
in New Hampshire with the mission act
you know veterans have a choice of
getting their care in in the VA or out
in in the community and I think that's a
good thing I mean I'm a veteran and I
like to have choice too but I mean we
really think you know we provide
veteran-centric care and uh and I'll say
it is easier providing all of that here
than having it fragmented throughout the
community so where we can build Services
that's what I want to do you know
everything's in the medical record and
and uh and um and you know it's it's
easier for the veterans we've added you
know surgical Services over the last
year like ear nose and throat we've had
an infectious disease more Cardiology
and and it's been growing and so it's
really wonderful for uh for veterans to
have access to those to those services
the last piece for you know for
strategic direction is just my eye on
infrastructure you know we've got a 70
year old campus that you know I I don't
want to worry about whether we're going
to have another pipe like you know or
things and and so we work with with the
VA to have an aggressive Capital
Improvement program in in place but you
know it takes time to build new
infrastructure in new buildings but you
know we are committed to um
um you know continuing to work on this
infrastructure so this past January we
had a new urgent care and mental health
Annex that was built at the Manchester
VA you know Wonderful facility we have a
new Specialty Service Annex that will be
breaking ground on uh you know next year
we have a Women's Health Clinic uh to
serve our women veterans that's private
with private entrances uh and uh and
that's a a project that's upcoming will
probably break ground in late 23 or
early 24
many infrastructure projects that aren't
I'll say is appealing to the to the eye
but you know the uh the infrastructure
for utilities and all you know all that
stuff has to be upgraded you can't run
any hospital with you know 70 year old
utilities and things so there's a
there's a lot going on with that that
we're building
um I'm not sure whether folks had
mentioned we have this Franklin campus
that's that's
um uh going to be a veteran campus here
in New Hampshire that Governor sununu
had spearheaded in to the VA so one of
the things we're looking at is taking
this Tilton Clinic that we have and
looking to be able to expand and I say
how nice would that be to have something
nested with other veteran organizations
you know on that campus that comes to
fruition so that's one thing that we're
we're speaking about now to to continue
building that that infrastructure as
well as the other the other clinics
so um you know a lot lots going on but
certainly the eye in on on
infrastructure and uh and really kind of
driving us into uh the 21st century here
to be able to provide services that the
last the last piece that I'll
I'll mention here because I'm you know
I'm very
um mindful of not having a full-service
hospital here in New Hampshire and so
you know a lot goes into that but you
know we have relationships with our no
the VA down in Boston you know a 1A
complex tertiary Care Facility the VA in
up in White River but also have
wonderful relationships with the
facilities in in Manchester
um you know whether it be Catholic
Medical Center the Elliott and and um
even you know Concord Hospital and so
what we've done and this is just
starting in in uh you know another month
or so here but we've built an inpatient
embedded case management team and so
this consists of nursing staff and
social work staff that will physically
be in those private sector hospitals so
that when you know the uh the impatient
team that rounds on on our veterans the
VA will be side by side with them
rounding in those hospitals so the
veterans know that the VA is right there
you know with the medical team taking
care of them and that we're able to do a
smooth transition when it's time to
discharge and get that you know after uh
inpatient care
that we're able to facilitate right
there we make it much easier for that
hospital and in much easier for us to be
able to get them the appointments they
need and really have a smooth transition
back for that post discharge care so I'm
excited about that we haven't done that
uh previously and so that's our I think
our first foray and to get it you know
having a physical presence in in the
hospitals there so
so that's kind of where we're going
maybe some of the the challenges it's
it's exciting
um you know the pack tax certainly I
look forward to to more veterans you
know uh using our services and and uh
you know would ask for all of you that
that you know hopefully that helps give
you an idea of what we provide and I'd
ask that you know if you know of a
veteran in need is please refer them you
know our way and if we can't help them
we certainly will get them to the right
resource that uh that can so
you know representative Moffat you know
thank you for the time today and
everybody and and you know look forward
to any questions you may have thank you
Kevin it's a great brief uh I've been to
the your VA our VA a number of times uh
and I'm very grateful to for the great
service that I've gotten there and I
know you have some challenges some high
maintenance folks that that uh you take
take a lot of patience and and patients
meaning patience so thank you for what
you're doing thank you for being here
today know how busy you are and I know I
hated you something you came in the door
so uh I know that it's not easy
questions for Kevin uh representative
gagne
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question the match to VA are
they still dealing with agent orange
intakes yes as part of pectech we have
the the registry they come in and go to
our administrative medicine clinic get
on that registry and whatever you know
physicals are appropriate so so where do
they go from Manchester whether they go
from Manchester yeah
if surgery is required do they are they
sent to was it Roxbury they may go to
West Roxbury they might go to White
River Junction we may use the community
uh you know depending each patient case
would be individual on what those needs
are thank you thank you
representative Rollins
yes thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question what is the financial
threshold to be eligible to be to go to
the hospital
so is there a threshold or how much
money you can make or not make or well
there is and it's individual per each
person you know the the eligibility it
starts with service connection and a
disability rating is a big part of the
eligibility piece so you know anybody
that's service connected uh certainly
can be seen for those service connected
conditions anybody over 50 percent
service connected is able to get their
you know their full care there
um short of the service connection piece
it does go on a tiered schedule based on
income possible service connection and
um um and they look at each person
individually with that so it kind of
depends on that but thank you okay
now the questions
thank you Mr chair but just to Echo the
uh the chair some a veteran who's used
the VA counseling program I just want to
say what a wonderful
service you provide to Veterans and and
I probably wouldn't have gone if it was
another veteran told me what a wonderful
job you do and they still get the
follow-up calls and uh and it's meant a
lot to me I just want to say thank you
oh thank you I'm sure love I really
appreciate it I know that you know the
folks are dedicated to what they do and
they work hard so thank you
all right seeing no more hands Uh Kevin
thank you so much and uh and best wishes
keep up the good work and um we'll uh
maybe see you down the road maybe we'll
see you in two years who knows I will
leave contact cards here if people would
like them and certainly give me a call
anytime with any questions or something
thank you sir before I introduce the
final uh guest today
um Christina Dyer is in the back there
Christina is our researcher she's
already done some great work for us
we're lucky to have her Karen karawaki
is not here at the moment but she's our
Administrative Assistant helper person I
spoke with her earlier most of you know
Karen if you don't you'll see Karen so
Christina and Karen thank you for
helping us for your future help that I
know will be uh forthcoming not too much
you know we'll we'll be done in uh three
three more hearings probably
um and also before everybody leaves
after uh Kimberly finishes uh if you
could hang for like five minutes just a
few little housekeeping items before you
launch and having said that uh Kimberly
Kimberly McKay is the director of
Veteran or commandant I think is a
proper term you can correct us on that
at the uh at our wonderful Veterans Home
in Tilton
yes another big title big title right
um so thank you for having me I'm Kim
McKay I'm the commandant of the New
Hampshire veterans home
um have been there just this month I
will be finishing my first year so I
love coming out and being able to brag
about the facility
I did throw together a handout
um just to go through I don't know is it
does everybody know about the New
Hampshire Veterans Home
yes no okay
um so in 1890 it was created as and it's
still sometimes called the Tilton
Soldiers Home a lot of people will call
it that
um but it's right now it is a 250 bed
facility we have licensing for 250
Intermediate Care which means long-term
care not skilled so we don't do rehab we
just do long-term care so we're we have
250 bids the license the state of New
Hampshire the governor the governor
budgets us at 225 so we have a budget
for 225.
um but the real reality of
um Staffing as Kevin had mentioned is
that we cannot provide the services at
225 with the limited staff we have so we
have uh set a cap right now currently
and that changes constantly if we have
more staff we can take more residents
but we're we're capping at like 131
right now so unfortunately uh that's one
of our challenges you'll hear me talk a
little bit further down but about uh 50
or a half of them right now we have
about 50 residents on our dementia care
units and the rest live in our tar South
tar North or Welch units
uh mission statements is to provide the
best quality of life for the New
Hampshire veterans with dignity honor
and respect and I think if you uh ever
have a chance
um you could call me see if we are open
at this point uh we have opened our
doors and then covid comes and then we
have to close them again and
unfortunately right now we're on a
restricted uh visits for a couple of our
units because we do have active covid
and we are an outbreak break status but
if there's a ton that you would like to
come I would ask you to come and and
just get the feel of the facility you
will see how appreciative the residents
the veterans are and how much the staff
loves doing the work they're doing I
think if you do this type of work in the
medical field and you work with the
veterans you you love the work that you
do it's not just about the paycheck we
have staff that have been there for
years
and they become our family the veterans
become our family
so our current census right now is 127.
as I said we go up to 131 and that
changes depending on when we can do
admissions or if someone's passed we
have 117 men 10 women and our our
average age right now is about 84. so uh
that has been staying consistent since
I've been there it's about 84 years old
branch of military so for the people
that have served this is always a
conversation especially around the card
table because how many marines does it
take how many of this how many that and
uh who's better who's not uh so I
whenever I do a presentation I like to
just give the breakdown of our current
population so right now we have 27
residents in the air that had certain
Air Force One in the air guy uh guard
most of our residents are army right now
54 residents one Coast Guard what she
gets a lot of uh ribbon about that not
being real
um I feel bad for him because he has no
no allies with him uh three Marines
which uh one of the
um Council executive Council says that's
good that's that's a good no and uh 41
Navy we do have a couple of residents
who actually have served in multiple
branches
um so they they it's interesting who
they'll say they identify as though so
um and then I always try to uh just talk
about the conflict era we're seeing the
World War II veterans fade very quickly
um the last time I did the data for this
was uh for a presentation probably about
three months ago and we had 17 World War
II veterans and so when I did it this
week and I saw that it was 14. it's just
really sad to see that era
passing uh Korean conflict 40 residents
and a Vietnam era we have 64 and then we
have nine residents who served during
peacetime
so
um just a kind of just a snapshot of our
resident population
I also put in here some challenges and
achievements so
um with every uh challenge we have we
try to create a solution and these two
challenges are very related so a
challenge has been Recruitment and
Retention of Staff both clinically and
non-clinically in the state system in
the past you would uh you would never
have an opening in a maintenance or a
dietary or Food Service people would
take part-time jobs to come in to get
their foot in the door to be wait for a
full-time job and we don't see that
anymore we're not we're just not seeing
that we have vacancy rates of about 34
percent and our nursing vacancy rates
about 48 percent and which is why we
can't go to the full
225 but we're also right now
experiencing a huge shortage in our food
service area and that is because we pay
as a state so low compared to what they
can make in the community so in this in
a in our facility if you're making to
twelve dollars and sixty cents an hour
and you have to know somebody's diet
their allergies the consistency of their
food there's a lot of pieces of that or
I can go to McDonald's and make 15 an
hour and I can make a burger make a
burger make one without ketchup make a
burger make a burger it's just a lot
less responsibility so we're seeing
these these hardships in all of our
areas and of course as Kevin had
mentioned we're feeling it in the
nursing field we've been feeling it for
a while there so some of the things we
did we launched a licensed nursing
assistant program our we have staff uh
that that actually teach the program and
so we've created part-time positions and
we hire the potential student and they
come on as an LNA trainee and then they
work for us and they get learn as you
learn they take the class us on site
with our residents and they're getting
paid as an employee and then they take
the exam and then they go into a
full-time position we're about ready to
graduate our third group of students and
that will be 16 new lnas just in our
system in the last six months so that's
been or maybe eight months that's been a
huge help because the lnas again a lot
of facilities in the private sector are
able to offer sign-on bonuses we just
don't have that option in the state
system so we have to figure out a way to
recruit people and then keep people so
we want to retain them so creating a
ladder for Education we created a
medication nursing assistant program
with the Board of Nursing that just got
approved in December and so we can have
lnas who have been L A's for two years
take this course in-house and then they
can also pass medications that don't
require assessments under the the
supervision of a nurse
we have reclassed a vacant position to
focus on recruitment so we have a
full-time recruiter just looking at how
to get out to job fairs how to get to
high schools how to get
um
our name anywhere we can we are on
College boards you know hiring boards
we're trying a lot of different things
that we hadn't tried in the past and
we're improving our onboarding and our
retention support So when someone comes
on it's just it's important to keep them
there but they need to feel like part of
the team they need to feel like they're
doing a good job so our orientation we
really looked at that how do we do that
and that's really piecing people up
together as a team so if I have a
question I have somebody go to if I
don't know how to
approach this resident I have somebody
to go to so they have a peer that
they're connected with and then we've
been doing uh communication Improvement
across the board when I came in a year
ago not everybody had email which was
just really surprising to me because I I
was so accustomed to having email and my
third day there we had a covet outbreak
and so I was saying let's push out the
email everybody needs to know so we're
all aware and what we're going to do so
I was surprised that only 50 of the
staff had email it is a cost and but to
me it felt like it was an important cost
so we now have email for everybody it's
not a hierarchy everybody needs the same
information
we also have a lot more staff meetings I
they they name everything at the
veterans home so it's called
conversations with the commandant so I
meet with every staff member quarterly
on every shift so I by the time I've
said the agenda the 14th time I'm kind
of boring myself but for them at two in
the morning they're happy that I'm on
their shift to see them so we're seeing
a lot of that kind of improvement and
then
I uh talk about the census
um and that it relates to Staffing we
can't improve our census and meet the
need of all the residents or all the
veterans in the community and so we can
actually increase our staffing so I have
it's a twofold we need to increase our
staffing to increase our census so we're
trying to at least meet the needs of the
people that we have there
um the residents are they expect a high
quality of care the families expect a
high quality care and our staff want to
give nothing but a high quality care so
that's where we set that number we've
Consolidated units because we had units
where they were half full and so we have
them on all on the same unit to have our
staffing be able to meet the needs we've
extended or expanded light duty return
work programs to keep the employees in
the workplace if you can do something
then maybe you can't do your original
job but maybe you can do something else
in another area we have been doing that
um we have increased the number of
volunteers we are very lucky we have 100
plus volunteers that come in on a
regular basis
um that help us out from folding laundry
to waitressing in our dining rooms
because we're short staffed and then we
mandate for nursing staff every nurse
and LNA does an extra four-hour Block in
the two-week pay period so they have a
little control over when that mandate is
taking place but that helps us meet the
need a bit
um I put the next one in here is about
revenue streams uh not many people know
that we have three uh sources
um two so the first biggest one is the
general fund we're about 47 uh funded by
the general fund the VA meaning that
their their benefits um through the per
diem rate of uh VA payments is about 29
and then private pay or room and board
so if somebody has thirty thousand
dollars or more than uh over for income
not their home but income uh and assets
then they pay a higher rate until they
hit that thirty thousand dollar less
and then in here I talk about Chris key
strategic priorities again growing the
census when I we've gone about 10
percent in the last year we are at 121
now we're moving up to 131. meet the VA
survey requirements we're required to be
surveyed every year by the VA they come
in and and check us out it's our report
card and so I always look forward to it
I know people get really nervous about
it but I always think it's this is where
we can find out if we're doing a great
job and we always hear you're doing a
great job so
um so that happens every April so we're
looking forward to that uh health and
life safety initiatives
um what can we do to ensure that our
facility is safe for all that come in
all that live there and different
um projects so we're always looking at
projects people ask us what can they
help with and I think the gentleman back
here was talking about our project of
our in our dementia unit we're putting
up these um they're almost like vinyl on
our exit doors because a lot of the
veterans try to exit seek and so it
looks like a bookcase so it doesn't look
like a door so we're and our partners
our biggest support our veteran service
organizations and so they will ask us
what do you need what could make this
facility safer and we give these
projects out and then they fundraise for
us we would not be as in such a great
shape if we didn't have all the support
from the community
we have to increase our contracted
Services we're trying to get uh
temporary nurses a contract for we have
a contract currently it's not been
producing any nurses so we need to try
to get a new contracted service and then
our it infrastructure is pretty poor the
building's older so we just got a
a grant through the Opera funds for 1.1
million dollars to update our Wi-Fi
system I can't tell you how many uh 84
year olds are having they have their
phone they're on their they're on like
Zoom meetings with their families in
their rooms and so if it doesn't work
well I hear about it so we definitely
need to do a better job because the
building is so old so it's hard for the
Wi-Fi to work well so we're going to be
putting that in place
any questions
thank you Kim that's a great brief very
nice PowerPoint very military power
I see you only have three Marines there
it's the good news it's enough to change
the light bulb though right uh see
that's I wasn't going to say the joke
but that's what I hear if any of those
three Marines give you trouble uh let
Joe Kenny know and he will take
appropriate action questions uh uh
representative gagne
thank you Mr chairman
coming down your uh your your background
for this position is it administrative
or medical
um so I am a I'm an uh I worked in the
hospital for 14 years as a medical
social worker so I have a Master's in
psychology
um and I'm a licensed nursing home
administrator so uh 14 years in a
hospital as a medical social worker I've
been with the state for 16 years I've
worked at DHHS at Glencliff which is a
psychiatric facility long-term care
facility and I also worked at the prison
for a long time uh overseeing the
Community Corrections there
works for me
other questions uh yes there wasn't a
short left
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here and uh I should declare a
conflict because they may be a resident
there someday and uh but my question is
the common Den is there anything that we
in the legislature can do to help with
some of your challenges and notice for
example you talked about vehicle
replacement and upgrade
um I know this is a budget year as well
and um if you need any help I guess I
can speak for myself personally but any
help as far as your budget to testify or
to uh work in this body to try to give
you the budget that you actually need to
perform your duties I think that's
incumbent upon all of us though
I appreciate that yes we are trying to
refund or uh there were unfunded
positions we've asked for those to be
refunded uh we do have older uh Vans and
our residents um there's uh all the
activities they do comes out of the
resident benefit fund that's all
donations from the community all
donations
um and they're very active they do a lot
of activities uh which requires a bus
with a wheelchair lift so our buses are
old so that is in the budget for this
year to the next two years to replace
our budgets I mean our buses but I will
say that
I really would love to see some kind of
educational program an incentive program
similar to what uh Kevin is talking
about we have to keep uh the staff there
so I would love to see us be able to
sponsor Stu staff so two lnas to become
LPNs licensed practical nurses two LPNs
to become RNs invest in the staff that
we have and say you know we are
appreciative that you're here we know
that you're committed to these veterans
and the cost is minimal at when I say
minimal and the big picture of things
it's twenty five thousand dollars for a
bridging program and it's a one-year
commitment so for if we sponsored four
people for one hundred thousand dollars
that would be amazing to have those
staff um stay with us and then we'd ask
for a commitment we can't you know hold
them to that but we would ask them for a
commitment for two years after their
education
other questions
Judy yes thank you Mr chair uh ma'am on
your presentation I feel you are really
care about your vision
and uh
keep going don't give up thank you and
also uh did you uh
you do have a
covid-19 there on one of the
one of the virgins yes right now we have
um we have covid we're in an outbreak
status we've had
um about uh 19 staff and we have seven
um veterans
um actually they just sent me an email
there's two more so nine veterans with
active covid
um this is the fourth outbreak since
I've been there in a year uh the one
thing I will say is that the outbreaks
are smaller
shorter duration because we're able to
identify that the residents right away
and because we have there many of them
or most of them are vaccinated and we
use the medications that are available
we have not had any deaths so I knock on
wood I ask for everybody's prayers to
keep that going but yes we do have it
and then it will go off and then we go
back on it depends on what's in the
community yes thank you
okay to finish up a couple quick
questions uh your oldest resident and
also the typical uh period of time that
someone stays there uh oldest resident
is a hundred so we do have a 100 year
old resident and we have someone in the
90s that are just right on the cusp
um I would say it's it really is so
fluid because it depends on when they
come in if you come in at 90 something
your stay is going to be shorter than if
you come in at 70. but
um
I would say a year or two you know we
have residents right now that have been
there for nine years and then some that
just came in
you might have touched on this but the
uh the youngest how old you have to be
to to be able to be eligible to to stay
there right it's not really an age it's
a medical need so you have to meet the
need to be in a long-term care setting
um so we don't have an age I think our
youngest person is in their late 60s
right now but we look at your medical
condition so it's not really an age
number
and this might have been touched on in
your handout uh but if somebody comes to
one of us and asks about uh the veterans
home
um how to find out if if they have a
relative that will qualify what's the
process what should we tell them I said
Mike I'll leave my cards too but the
contact information is here as well
um and if if you don't follow us on
Facebook our our Shameless plug is on
the bottom here as well and our site so
you could go there and there the forms
are there for application the um on our
website uh there is a admissions
Department that will take calls and walk
people through because sometimes it's
very individual too someone might know a
neighbor that needs to come in or
someone else may have a loved one or a
family member they want to come in or
some advocate for themselves
um just recently somebody said I'm just
making plans for the future so I want to
know I have a plan that my family
doesn't have to worry about it so you
could call call me and I can to connect
them or they can go on the website and
get the paperwork there
great excellent thank you Kim last call
questions for Kim
thank you so much and maybe we'll some
of us will see you in two years yeah and
please tour and president shurt lift
maybe a resident I heard uh let's give
you a good room and and he's uh already
old enough to qualify that's why I asked
that question so
thank you for having me thank you
okay folks uh so we're gonna finish up
uh I'll chat with Lori with
representative Kerry for a minute
representative shirtleff for just a
minute before he leaves uh somebody
asked me about like food drink coffee uh
yeah we had some there's some coffee
sightings earlier uh for hearings if if
we could stick to water and kind of keep
it oh you know so there's not ciao and
and uh drinks on the that people can see
uh if you need M M's to get through a
long session yeah sure just you know
just keep them below the table whatever
just so that it looks good that's about
all I can any questions for me I we're
gonna have a hearing a bunch of hearings
a week from today it's already been
published in the calendar you can look
at those so the presenters the sponsors
presumably will be in and uh we've got
those timed out you never know uh I know
some of you would know uh you never know
so you think you may have uh a lot of
testimony for some bills and you don't
and you have one you think is going to
be quick and it's not there's
representative Sherlock I'm sure has
seen seen it all so uh we'll try to keep
it moving and
um give everybody everyone a chance to
speak uh somebody asked me once about
are we going to ever limit uh testimony
it's just hard to say we'll we'll see if
there's a big lineup you know we'll
we'll uh do we need to do I don't
anticipate that being a problem you know
last year was a pretty late
uh load for the most part
um the
27th I've given Karen the list of all
the bills or measures resolutions that
we don't get to next week we'll
hopefully finish on the 27th uh you may
have seen there's a uh
is that Ken back there sure
um I've you have a blue folder and those
who weren't here we'll save those
folders for them uh we we have I think
what's going to be a high profile
measure is the uh the one with regard to
Article Five and I'm hearing that uh
there will be 50 to 100 people that will
are interested in attending if not
testifying so that possibly might and
it'll be the very last one we do
tentatively on the 27th in the afternoon
um probably in here but uh once I hear
more from some of the Article Five folks
if if they know there's going to be a
lot a lot of people then we don't want
to not let them into a hearing so stand
by on that one on the 27th and then
after that I'll talk with representative
shurtleff uh we'll have an exact session
possibly uh the first Friday in February
I think that's the third and I'm
thinking that we maybe can get through
that who knows I think a lot of the
measures may be pretty easy for us to
deal with and vote on other ones there
might be some that will take some time
just don't know I'll talk to the ranking
member and we'll try to be ready for
that
and then uh so we can potentially finish
on the third
and then crossover last year we had like
two crossover items I don't know if
we'll have any or a couple probably not
much in April so uh those of you who
wanted to be on a committee that doesn't
take up all your time that you're you're
in a good good place I think
um anything anything for the good or the
order from anybody Mr chairman uh who
said Mr chairman me uh representative
gagne yes is this currently all the
bills that we have right now to to take
care of
yes I believe what Karen printed out uh
is what we've been assigned and I sent
you an email that listed everything I
could find that looked like was coming
our way so you should have you should
have what we're going to deal with
because I won't be here on the 27th
because I
okay then uh that's a hearing day so uh
thanks and please let us know if you can
be here for hearing
um and I heard from most everybody who
could not be here today for different
reasons uh executive session of course
you all know the drill if if if you
can't be here which will probably be in
the third uh you know let us know 24
hours in advance
and uh yeah you should know that drill
uh good question anything else uh yes
representative Massimo
oh yes uh especially new folks and
everybody uh we have our committee room
is right there we share it with child
and family law that's representative
Mark Pearson's uh uh committee I I spoke
to him and he said I could have first
choice of desks so uh thank you
represent Pearson and yeah you have a
drawer uh with your name on it to put uh
I used to put emergency food in mine uh
but that's your space uh it's rather
humble but it's yours so your name
should be on it if it's not let me know
thank you representative messinola
do we need
do we get an RSA book here
like they do in the other committees
question is do we get an RSA book here
um I know in education we had a big a
big fat RSA book uh represent Massimo
you've been here before uh
yeah not necessary I guess right uh yes
we there are certain statutes rsas that
are kind of uh veteran specific but
state federal it's kind of it's kind of
all over the place uh in terms of what
we might be dealing with good question
and the answer is apparently we don't
have such a book for this committee
yeah and Skip uh represent Rollins been
around too and you don't remember seeing
that either
okay yes representative Seibert
oh sure question was bringing an iPad in
iPod and I have one in my bag and I yeah
I sometimes use those to call up uh
bills or or statutes so great question
and I think yes you by all means I think
a iPad or a computer I know in some
committees some people put up these
really big computers and in that
sometimes when you screen from the
people that does it's not a good look
but I think what you describe a little
uh iPad iPod I guess iPad right uh yeah
that's that's great that's a great tool
you know as long as it's not like
something where people hide behind you
know
uh grab some carrot
just a quick comment on that
um during the clerk's training this year
they asked us to encourage people to
keep things down on their surface
because to have anything up interferes
with your relationship with the public
and to be respectful of their testifying
so with using your devices if we can
keep them in the same way we're keeping
our food you know as a sort of low-key
yeah thank you so she kind of reiterated
what I said so I'm sure that answers
your question uh there is no secession
bill this year
um that was a big one I think the the
article five one I think will be a high
I I know will be a high profile
well-attended uh session that I'm
looking forward to frankly that's uh
potentially a significant proposal we
had it last year uh I think this year
the the folks that are
uh pushing that or I've received a
number of calls maybe some of you have
too and um so they're really making an
effort to educate us as to you know
what's
true we're not true in that article 5
convention process so that'll be the
very last one we do
um on the 27th tentatively the next
week's calendar will come out and
confirm that so that's what's out there
and anything else representative your
lights on representative gagne uh
in regards to this article five yes we
have got emails and lots of phone calls
and do I need this steal me can you guys
hear me yeah all right uh
what we did Transportation when we had
the speed limit bill for Lake
Winnipesaukee the broads we we ended up
having to meet in the uh the state house
and representatives Hall And as far as
time limits I mean I ran that because
Tom had to go to another meeting so I
ran that that meeting
this is how effective pink cards were
so we set a time limit
for everyone equally three minutes and I
had one of my the people of our
Representatives just have a timer a
digital timer and when the three minutes
went up the person kind of sort of had
to finish the statement we give them a
little leeway but they all held to that
because we had like 300 and some odd
people who showed up yes education went
through that yesterday they had hours in
reps Hall on on a measure that they were
dealing with and uh and essentially
representative Reed had a proposal at uh
rules day in fact I asked her a question
some of you might recall uh they were
trying to with regard to rules governing
chairs and limiting uh being Equitable
or fair about limiting speech and if you
remember my question was to
representative Reed you know something
Sometimes some of you would know but
sometimes someone will come and testify
and they break down into tears I mean
I've seen it this is the question you
may have heard me ask her so if there if
we do have a time limit uh I
I don't want to be have someone who's
trying to compose himself and say what
okay you're two minutes is up sorry so
that's on me I'll but we'll all you know
talk about it and try to be reasonable
and fair and and uh I don't sense for
most of our men well it's hard to say
there you never know who's going to show
up so we'll play by you and we'll do the
best we can and do the right thing but
folks yeah thanks uh represent getting
it but actually I don't mind a lot of
people coming I I'm a Civics guy I like
peop I like a lot of people taking an
interest in what we do
um and hearing from them and uh I look
forward to that but we'll see uh which
which measures you know people and I
know Article Five certainly will
representative
for this committee okay right so we have
the win scheduled for next week and and
um I think I the we have the final I
think it's the final list of everything
we're going to get at this point I know
there's still assigning a few late
numbers uh so whatever we don't we have
next week's calendar scheduled so
whatever
we'll look at the final if it is final
list of measures that coming our way if
we can get them all done on the 27th
that if that if it's reasonable yeah
anything else
all right looking forward to seeing
everybody next Friday and uh ping me
anytime and uh we will press on thanks